[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à notre
programmation spéciale qui se poursuit
sur le voyage du pape au canada toujours
à edmonton en alberta il va célébrer cet
avant-midi dans le stade du commonwealth
où on attend quelques 65 mille personnes
peut-être même plus alors pour cette
émission je retrouve mon collègue alain
crevier spécialiste des affaires
religieuses bonjour alain bonjour
geneviève l'ethnologue huronne wendat
isabelle picard bonjour isabelle quiz
ndf joie et se joint à nous aujourd'hui
le professeur titulaire à la faculté de
théologie et de sciences religieuses de
l'université laval gilles routhier
bonjour monsieur routier bonjour alors
avant de
poursuivre un petit peu plus loin sur le
programme de la journée pour le pape on
va joindre une autre collaboratrice will
dean est paul qui elle se trouve sur le
terrain à edmonton alors qu'ils dînaient
temps ce 26e juillet c'est la fête de
sainte anne et de saint-joachim et le
pape ira d'ailleurs cet après-midi un
pèlerinage au lac sainte anne au nord
ouest d'amman tonnes mais d'abord parlez
nous du stade je pense qu'on attend
beaucoup beaucoup de monde
exactement ceux du fc énorme qu'est-ce
qui va se dérouler ici au stade comme un
waf sous montre exactement ce qui se
passe alors les gens qui commencent à
entrer tranquillement ce stade qui se
remplit parce qu'on attend
65000 personnes
vous le voyez sur le terrain il y à des
chaises blanches qui sont principalement
réservée pour les survivants des
pensionnats pour autochtones mais aussi
leurs proches il y aura d'autres
personnes qui seront à saisir sur le
terrain et il y a aussi un autre stade
celui cloud c'est un endroit adjacents
qui est mis en place pour que 5000
autres personnes puissent suivre qu'est
ce qui est en train de se dérouler ici
au stade commonwealth alors je vous
parlais de quelque chose d'énorme qui
est en train de se dérouler parce qu'on
nous a aussi dit que les 65 mille
billets réservés pour le stade ont tous
été distribués et si vous voulez 7 mais
cela j'aimerais vous dire qu'au coeur de
cette célébration et sera question des
peuples autochtones le pape qui veut
partager un message d'espoir bien sûr
mais également de réconciliation et tout
au long de cette messe et sera aussi
question d'éléments forts qui font
partie de la culture autochtone un stade
à la place qui est réservé aux grands
mères la place des aînés il y aura des
liens qui se seront fait un tout au long
de cette messe et il sera également
question d'autres éléments là qui font
partie de la culture autochtone je peux
aussi vous dire qu'au sein des personnes
qui vont participer à cette célébration
il y à des diacres autochtone des femmes
aussi que mon faire des leaks heures
aujourd'hui alors vraiment une grande
messe qui est en train de se dérouler
j'aimerais vous dire deux éléments
importants à surveiller une opération
colossale imaginez vous qu'on va tenter
de distribuer la sainte communion à
70000 personnes en 10 à 12 minutes on
verra si l équipe en mesure de relever
ce défi et bien sûr le vêtement que va
porter le pape françois alors on le sait
c'est une artiste autochtone qu'il a
confectionnée alors ça serait
intéressant j'ai nous avons tous hâte de
voir qu'est ce que le pape va porter
aujourd'hui alors revenons sur cette
multi sur cette personne à cette foule
qui s'est déplacée pour voir le pape il
y a des gens d'ici de différentes
provinces il ya aussi des étrangers qui
ont fait le voyage tout spécialement
pour voir le pape françois voici
quelques personnes que nous avons
rencontrées pour vous on les écoute oui
enfin je dis non
mike weir à des bugs gamine
she's like a woman accomplie
tous ces
livres en france et j'y serai le money
comme calgary tout y est on est au big
match nous étions en argentine à buenos
aires il ya quelques années nous avons
été dans son église la gaieté cardinal b
on ne suit non
on va prier pour les familles
oui on voit qu'elle est fidèle qui sont
venus d'un peu partout mais je le répète
c'est le parterre n'est ce pas le
parterre du stade qui est réservé aux
survivants autochtone c'est bien ce à
widnes est exact exactement
principalement pour les survivants et
d'autres personnes oui bien on voit en
ce moment des images d'un coeur qui je
crois est là pour justement distraire ou
occuper la foule en attendant l'arrivée
du pape
oui écoutilles geneviève nous on est
arrivé là ici à 5 heures heure locale
alors 6 9 heures heure de l'est et déjà
il y avait foule il y avait des
centaines de personnes qui attendaient
devant la porte pouvoir entrer et pour
pouvoir occuper ces gens là bas en
attendant l arrivée du pape il y a
effectivement des coeurs on a même
entendu un chant de gorge ici au stade
commonwealth où elles les ont applaudis
après cette prestation alors vraiment
des gens qui sont là qui attendent
patiemment et un petit mot pour le faire
avant que le pape arrive ici avec sa
part mobile il va d'abord à lille du
côté du stade club pour pouvoir saluer
les fidèles ensuite il va venir ici
alors bien sûr on verra quelle qu'elle
accueille ses fidèles et autres
personnes lui réserve tout cela ça va se
dérouler aujourd'hui cette messe en
avant midi et c'est d'ailleurs la
première grande messe devant ce type de
foule la star 65000 personnes qui se
déroule ici à edmonton pour cette visite
historique du pape francs voilà le pape
qui devrait arriver dans une dizaine de
minutes merci beaucoup une dînette à
plus tard
alors notre collègue tiffany rocha
talent se trouve à l'extérieur de ce
stade du commonwealth alors stifani vous
avez pu recueillir justement les
impressions de gens qui vont assister à
cette messe
oui qui continuent d'arriver d'ailleurs
parce que on n'a pas de véhicule qui
sont autorisés autour du stade donc
beaucoup de gens qui prennent les
transports en commun pour revenir et ce
sont des vagues vraiment de centaines de
personnes qui affluent devant le stade
commonwealth qui attendent pour pouvoir
rencontrer beaucoup de gens et comme
vous le dîner de vous préciser il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent de
l'étranger pour venir jusqu'ici être
deux pour voir le pape on a vu quand
même quelques personnes qui portaient
des tee-shirts orange pour rappeler
cette mission que le pape françois ces
données de centrer cette visite autour
des peuples autochtones et donc
certaines personnes nous en dit que oui
c'était très important pour eux que
cette mission soit précisé que le pape
parle de réconciliation de guérison de
ses excuses qu'il a fait hier mais la
plupart des gens à qui nous avons parlé
sont là parce qu'ils sont catholiques et
c'est une rare occasion pour eux de voir
le pape françois il a très peu
d'événements publics ici lors de cette
visite à edmonton c'est d'ailleurs un
des seuls événements où les gens peuvent
venir le voir et beaucoup veulent voir
espère le voir de plus près il y avait
même un monsieur qui avait des jumelles
pour pouvoir voir le pape et avoir ce
sentiment des proches alors c'est ça
c'est très important pour eux de voir le
chef de l'église catholique et pour
certains c'est l'occasion d'une vie de
voir
ce pape françois on a recueilli
certaines de ces réactions écoutez-le
[Musique]
dans l'audio et un plus bas à
gauche de
mes quatre amis
et les gens continuent d'affluer ici
avec leur petit sac en plastique parce
qu'on leur a demandé de venir avec un
sac transparent pour avoir le contenu
beaucoup d'eau de nourriture en espérant
voir le pape mais ce sera encore une
bonne heure d'attentes pour eux avant de
que la masse critique voilà merci
beaucoup tiffany roquettes avorton
coutard merci
au revoir
alors alain on a vu des gens qui sont
d'avenir d'amérique latine c'est
d'autant plus intéressant comment
windows ou vient justement le pape
françois oui c'est curieux parce que je
peux pas faire autrement que de me
rappeler ça fait jet set des hommes
c'est vrai lui il ya en 2013 après la
nomination de l'élection de françois je
suis allé à buenos aires est enquêté sur
son passé conduit un peu trop peu
importe que peu d'importance et j'avais
parlé à son secrétaire on se quitte à
particulier qui me disait d'aller voir
ils resteront pas longtemps à ramlé
savent sa patrie c'est buenos aires
l'aise puisqu'ils aiment faire servir
d'un match de foot
et de toute façon puisque j'étais un peu
étonné je me tais c'est quand même
maintenant berg ollioules devienne pas
françois le yard jeune et je lui
demandais va voyager voyagera pas de yam
pas beaucoup le voyage je pense que
c'est pas du poids très entiché de ce
genre de choses là là ça va être un pack
différent de ce que vous avez connu et
alors il a voyagé panache il est
toujours votre casque sachez-le entendu
récemment dire qu'ils n'avaient pas
l'intention de retourner en argentine et
non seulement ça il y aura des 37e 38e
voyage et j'ai remarqué quelque chose de
ta c'est particulier c'est que françois
parle souvent des périphéries
existentielle mais aussi géographique et
il a lequel il a le culot si vous me
permettez l'expression noble d'allier à
des endroits où c'est risqué je pense à
la république centrafricaine pleine
guerre civile il débarque l'iphone en
des endroits où ça joue dû y aller au
soudan
avant d'annuler son voyage là c'est ce
voyage qui comme je vous l'aï dit je le
disais hier pour moi c'est pas un voyage
ordinaire c'est pas un voyage pointe
elle à l'image normal il ya quelque
chose d'ici qui est de l'ordre de drames
de la tragédie humaine et il vient faire
ça quand les gens se déplacent comme ça
pour venir voir le pape à votre avis
c'est le pape françois pour ceux qui les
nuits françois aussi si le pape
la tête de l'église catholique
je pense que c'est les deux ouais ouais
de place saint pierre je me souviens
d'une italienne qui m'a raconté un jour
se plaint tout le temps appelé mercredi
ses plaques et elle me disait de les
gens qui sont ici ce sont des touristes
qui descendent de trastevere et qui a
réduit voir le pape mais ne se fait pas
d'eux des croyants et ça fait pas que
françois bon les convertir pour autant
pour mettre les choses à plat en
perspectif mais je me souviens d'une
fois où j'étais en allemagne avec benoit
16 artistes pas eclu je couvrais
l'événement qui avait pour la messe du
pape un million de personnes et c'est
impressionnant tout le monde disait
voilà un pape tellement
intellectuellement un concept que je
peux pas les gens
s'étaient plaints et quand le pape a dit
à un moment donné bon va faire si
l'ensemble il ya un million personnes
qui se sont tus et qui ont fait un
moment de prière c'était incroyable
alors je pense que françois c'est un
personnage différent des autres je pense
qu'on s'y attache et je pense que
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas des
catholiques ou non pratiquants qui
l'aiment beaucoup parce qu'il dit des
fois des choses qui semblent sortir de
la doctrine pas toujours vrai nom mais
c'est l'impression qu'ils donnent
maintenant on dit que la journée bon
c'est la sainte-anne aujourd'hui et la
saint-joachim pour ceux qui ne sauraient
pas ce intense et la mer et
saint-joachim c'est le père de marie
donc les grands parents maternels de
jésus et isabelle pour les autochtones
c'est une fête en tout cas la sainte
anne qui est célébrée qui est un moment
fort de leur de leurs pratiques
catholiques oui pour les pour les
autochtones catholique bien sûr parce
qu'il ya de la diversité au niveau des
religions et de la spiritualité sur les
autochtones mais entre autres au québec
chez les immigrés les attikameks le 26
juillet c'est une fête importante les
gens descendent à 52 po près on voit
c'est la même chose qui se passe du côté
du lac sainte anne en alberta pour
célébrer sa tante qui est en fait donc
la grand-mère et c'est surtout ça c'est
cet aspect de grand-mère d'années que
revêt représente en fait s'installe pour
les i nous et pour plusieurs autochtones
et vous savez je le disais hier quand
les premiers missionnaires sont arrivés
ils ont voulu trouver les bonnes
ficelles pour évangéliser pour attirer
les autochtones à la religion à
catholique et la sainte anne dans ce
qu'elle représente comme femmes fortes
comme femme qui fait des guérisons aussi
au tout de suite été un élément
accrocheur pour les autochtones et la
tradition là s'est transmise jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et pourquoi ce com comment
élaborer sur ceux sur la place des aînés
dans la culture autochtone qu'est ce qui
est important là dedans la transmission
du savoir la sagesse qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un peu tout ça enfin les aînés
sont les gardiens les gardiens de
l'histoire ou des histoires les gardiens
de la culture aussi aujourd'hui on est
en 2022 souvent ce sont les derniers
locuteurs dans plusieurs communautés
dans plusieurs nations donc évidemment
ils ont une vision du monde qu'ils ont
ils ont la patience nous enseigne
énormément à travers des paroles mais
parfois aussi à travers le style ans à
travers la réflexion et on a beaucoup
évidemment de respect pour les années
puisqu'ils l'ont vu ils sont passés à
travers différentes épreuves et il nous
enseigne ce sont un peu les enseignants
de la culture traditionnelle et de la
spiritualité dans les communautés
évidemment il ya une coupure mourir à
cause des pensionnaires dont la robe des
années 60 dont toutes sortes de choses
la loi sur les indiens est venue
bouleverser nos vies mais les 1 et reste
qu'ils ont une place prépondérante à
l'intérieur des communautés et ça ça
vaut pour toutes les nations autochtones
c'est
absolument c'est important partout
évidemment les choses ont changé la
modernité s'est inscrite de façon
différente mais quand même dans les
communautés autochtones les aînés ont
une place et quand il parle on les
entend et on les écoute alain vous
vouliez dire quelque chose je trouve que
ça nous confronte tellement avec notre
société où on seulement qu'est ce que
c'est que dieu
je suis à 85 ans je réponde me pose la
question mais qu'est ce que c'est que
d'être jeu quelle est la place des aînés
dans notre société la crise la pandémie
nous a tellement mis face à nos
responsabilités de société face aux
années et je parlais à ma été labrecque
saganash il ya un an de ça qui me disait
elle veut être la meilleure personne la
meilleure version d'eads même face à sa
grand-mère de qui elle va chercher
l'apprentissage de sa de la langue
maternelle qu'elle n'a jamais eue donc
voilà on voit les le questionnement face
à cette population vieillissante chez
nous ayant un model look qui était
intéressant est que le pape veut
travailler l'espace est important pour
lui mais ce routier
la place
des personnes âgées
des aînés dans le discours dans les
préoccupations du pape françois c'est
important oui il en a parlé souvent est
d'ailleurs la première lecture
aujourd'hui il va faire mention il va
commencer par
maintenant
honorons les nos ancêtres qui dans leur
génération et c'est alors ça sera centré
des la liturgie de la parole sur les
années mais c'est une vraie
préoccupation pour le pape et si je puis
dire bien sûr les gens vont rencontrer
vont à la rencontre du pape françois
pour cette célébration mais ils vont
vivre également plus que ça de voir
ensemble et c'est ça le signe peut-être
le plus puissant de voir ensemble des
autochtones et des allochtone réunis
autour d'une même table partageant le
même mais ça ça c'est le symbole du
point de vue symbolique par rapport aux
rencontres qu'il a eues hier c'est
vraiment ce qui va marquer cette
célébration de mettre ensemble des gens
que l'histoire a divisé et où il n'y a
pas eu de vraies rencontres
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelque
chose me seront aussi sur sainte anne
pour les catholiques maintenant bien sûr
comme étant la mère de marie c'est
important mais c'est un culte qui
quittent quand même relativement récent
et apparaît seulement 6e siècle j'ai cru
lire quelque part oui il se développe
surtout aux 12e et il se répand au
xvième siècle et est chez
particulièrement chez les marins bretons
qui vont le faire lui faire traverser
l'atlantique et depuis ce temps là
simple de beaupré est un lieu
emblématique
pour et pas seulement pour les
allochtone mais qui devient un lieu de
rencontre et imaginer
c'est un lieu au bord du fleuve au bord
du grand fleuve un lieu privilégié de
rencontres comme l'était également
autour du saguenay alors c est comme les
lacs 50 aujourd'hui alors bien sûr il y
a cette référence aux aînés il ya cette
préférence à sainte anne mais également
le lieu est déterminant parce que tous
les lieux de pèlerinage sont sur des eux
qui parlent d'eux-mêmes déjà oui parce
que je pense que sainte anne de beaupré
ce lieu en tout cas c'est là où se sont
échoués des marins bretons qui ont
construit la toute première chapelle
dédiée à sainte anne sur ce continent
maintenant on disait merci beaucoup mais
sur une si on disait
le pape on l'a dit plus tôt en début de
ce début de sa visite le pape est une
des personnes les 10 personnes les plus
protégés au monde et cet événement avec
des milliers personnes l'on parle de
65000 personnes représentent sans doute
des défis de sécurité dont je parle je
retrouve marcel savard l'ex directeur
adjoint est sorti du québec bonjour
marcel bonjour je dis alors dites nous
dans un stade comme celui là on fait
qu'il ya des gens dans un autre stade à
côté puis on a d'autres dans ce gros là
j'imagine que c'est un dispositif de
sécurité imposant
qui comme dans toutes les circonstances
les contextes où le pape se déplacent
surtout ici au canada face aux
autochtones on veut pas non plus qu'ils
paraissent trop où l'on peut imaginer
qui est imposant oui tout à fait il est
imposant et il ya des moments forts et
c'est un des gars en matière de sécurité
sans fin et c'est un moment fort pour la
sécurité actuellement quand le pack se
retrouve ce n'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'on appelle bain de foule parce que il
ne sera pas directement
dans la foule a serré des mains mais
c'est un moment fort parce que ya
soixante mille personnes
est évidemment oui des gens qui scrute à
l'entrée les personnes les sacs
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre il ya d'autres
spécialistes qui sont probablement en
train de faire une vigie importante sur
la circulation aérienne qui pourrait y
avoir vous savez dans un stade comme ça
c'est une faible
facile pour quelqu'un est exposé en voit
juste pardon il est exposé ouais il est
exposé parce que le stade lui même à
partir du haut des airs c'est très très
facilement localisables il ya des gens
aussi des équipes spécialisées qui fonda
surveillance pour les drones donc on a
vraiment au dessus de ce site d'un autre
temps qui a été mis par dont il ya une
note notamment c'est une note qui était
officiellement émises par transports
canada aux personnes qui sont des
pilotes d'avion que ce soit des petits
avions ou des gros et une zone
d'exclusion et ça inclut aussi les
drones donc on est en train de
surveiller l'espace aérien sur le sol on
regarde on scrute les bagages on regarde
et il ya même des personnes qui sont en
civil qui ont une expertise en
un profilage d'été visions et ouais
c'est ça et le mot profilage peut
participer plusieurs personnes mais ce
sont des gens qui ont une expertise pour
détecter les gens qui ont un
comportement qui n'est pas compatible
avec tous les comportements qu'on voit
des fidèles des gens qui veulent
rencontrer le pape donc ces gens là ont
cette expertise là pour être capable de
cibler des personnes qui
ne vont pas avec l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
et à partir de là on va juste faire une
enquête un petit peu plus poussée on va
peut-être aller les rencontrer leur
parler vous savez c'est tellement
sensible actuellement c'est que tout est
à le doigté dans la poche comment on
fait ça comme on a peur des gens il ya
des gens qui peuvent avoir un
comportement qui ne semble pas être
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre mais qui
finalement ce sont tout simplement des
gens qui ont une perception différente
vous savez on regarde là la pac comme
vous l'avez très bien dit en partant on
parle des dix personnes les plus
protégés au monde mais vous savez on
peut avoir quelqu'un qui veut se faire
un nom tout simplement aucune l'objectif
politique qui décide on en voit beaucoup
d'ailleurs aux états unis des gens qui
veulent tout simplement se faire un nom
la deuxième période de personnes qu'on
surveille c'est ce qui semble perturbé
mentalement ça c'est des gens qui
ont vraiment une vision de la société
d'avenue du pape qui mentalement les
perturber a décidé de passer à l'action
et enfin on à toute personne ou tout
groupe qui pourrait avoir un intérêt
les groupes qui ont un intérêt
contre la
religion catholique c'est une chose mais
vous savez il ya même des groupes qui
pour eux d'avoir cette espèce d'un
moment entre guillemets de gloire de
paraître sur l'ensemble des réseaux
mondiaux parce que c'est ça l'enjeu
actuellement la visite du pape elle est
diffusée à travers le monde donc d'avoir
cette espèce d'opportunités de faire
parler d'eux aucun rapport avec la
religion catholique avec le pape et est
tout simplement c'est un moment où il ya
une diffusion mondiale de l'événement
donc on est vraiment dans cette espèce
de perspectives et après je terminerai
en vous disant que les moments forts
vulnéraire de vulnérabilité ç'a toujours
été dans ce genre de situation l'arrivée
après ça c'est de se rendre
vulnérable devant soixante mille
personnes donc ils échouent convaincu
qui doit pas y avoir beaucoup beaucoup
le pape doit pas aimer beaucoup d'avoir
des plexiglas face à lui et enfin le
départ donc ce sont trois moments clefs
qui pour les forces de l'ordre sont
vraiment capital ils doivent absolument
être très concentré au moment où tout ça
parce que le pape sera protégé par un
texte qui glace veut dire dans la pâte
mobile ou quand il sera en train de
célébrer la main il arrive je n'ai pas
vu la scène il va arriver
la scène où il va célébrer la messe est
ce que la scène elle même elle est si
vous voulez protéger par des espèces de
plexiglas par balle en trop je ne sais
pas je vous dis que il arrive dans
plusieurs de ces événements ou des
personnes de haut rang qui sont
régulièrement visés par des attentats
que quand il se montre en public devant
soixante mille personnes en l'occurrence
on va installer des plaques de glace
pour les gens on ne voit pas la
différence sont du plexiglas impeccable
mais qui ont encore une protection
maintenant est-ce que c'est dans la
nature même de ce pas
d'accepter sort je ne suis pas certain
avec tout ce que j'ai lu entendu
peut-être vos invités pourraient mieux
fil aux documents ouais mais il est
possible qu'on puisse installer de tels
types de protection mais il faut que
absolument la personne principal soit
d'accord et bien c'est un autre débat en
effet je remercie beaucoup pour vos
lumières marcel savard au revoir
pourquoi alors alain justement vous avez
réagi lorsque monsieur savard a dit ça
n'est pas la personnalité celui qui
donne king qui doit être protégée et
c'est pas acquis que le pape lui
souhaite autant mesures de protection
non non hier je regardais l'image de cet
homme comme étant 85 de l'alsace
transporté qui est poussé dans son
fauteuil et il arrive et tout ce que je
vois c'est une dizaine de gardes du
corps qui parle dans leur marche dans
leur coller et c'est ça l'image oui
c'est ça alors on dit souvent qu'elle
image c'est le message est un message
lancé tom levier se recueillir la flamme
en garde du corps on note stable j'ai
aucune idée si des gens du canada de 2
les gares de suisse je peux pas vous
dire je sais pas ces choses là mais j'ai
comme l'impression que lui de sortir un
cinquième à l'inde avec ça il y avait
peut-être dans le milieu sont
particuliers peut-être 4,52 sur celui
qui avait tenté d'assassiner jean paul
ii avait dit dans une entrevue qu'il
était extrêmement facile d'abattre
francoual au vatican et j'ai pas de
doute cet homme là il fait de la pac
mobile décapotable et je pense qu'ils
privilégient le contact de ce type là
alors je sais pas se trouver que
monsieur savaria parler de l'équilibré à
essayer d'atteindre pour pas que ces
mesures de sécurité viennent nuit et aux
messages et à la casse a joué parce que
dans ce cas ci je m'excuse mais le juge
insiste mais je pense que le message est
aussi dans l'image
je trouvais ça très fier de voir cette
image là d'un homme qui vient de loin
pour porter un message à des situations
tragiques de tragédie et tous ces gens
qui se passe dans l'ordre qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette image mais sur
routier hier quand on a vu le pape
justement
parcourir
la distance qui le séparait du cimetière
du site du pont swan du pensionnat
blaska site entouré justement de ses
gardes du corps
oui alain ont raison c'est à dire c'est
un homme qui ne se soucie pas trop de la
protection et ir c'est également
ce n'était pas une vedette rock qui
rentrait en scène c'était non seulement
un homme recueilli qui regardaient la
terre et le silence comme il l'a dit
mais également c'est il faisait pas des
salutations tout le monde c'est un
pénitent et il la définit comme dans la
tradition du 12e siècle justement où il
y avait des pèlerinages pénitentielle il
s'est présenté comme un pénitent et sa
situation de mobilité réduite fait
également qu'il est encore plus démunis
plus vulnérables et plus
soumis à ce que les autres vont lui
donner et c'est pas une personnalité qui
s'imposent mais c'est une personnalité
qui s'efface et qui veut précisément
disparaître et laisser de la place aux
autres d'ailleurs il a dit avant même
d'arriver qui voulait faire de ce voyage
au canada un voyage
pénitentielle ça veut dire faire
pénitence et ça ça va avec les demandes
de pardon qui a fait hier n'est ce pas
exactement c'est à dire
le pèlerinage pénitentielle c'est une
catégorie qui vient du 12e siècle et
lorsque quelqu'un avec comme une faute
il entreprenait comme pénitents comme
repentant et avec les mortifications que
comportait le voyage bien sûr mais
d'autres mortification d'autres
préparation spirituelle pour
manifester à travers son corps et à
travers sa démarche ce qu'il veut dire
et c'est là également que le message le
plus fort
c'est qu'il soit venu et c'est également
ce qu'il ce qu'il fait son action et son
attitude
c'est à dire ceux en tout cas de mon
point de vue ce que j'ai vu hier ce
n'était pas comme comme peuvent parfois
on voit si on compare ça à d'autres et
on en voit souvent des excuses ce ne
sont pas des excuses de fonctions parce
qu'il est pape bon il doit bien faire ça
puis à
son corps défendant et à reculons on va
les faire des excuses non s'étaient
sentis c'était habitées on le voyait
dans son dans son corps dans son
attitude dans son intonation et c'était
pas simplement une têtes parlantes qui
fait une déclaration qu'ensuite on
s'envoie mais il a fait ça dans le
silence et le recueillement qui était
dans ce lieu au moment où il est arrivé
et il la respecte et ça et ce n'est
qu'après ya eu une espèce de deux grand
ouf ce n'est qu'après où il est on est
passé à autre chose mais c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui c'est un type qui veut
la rencontre qui veut le contact qui
veut être avec ces personnes là et à
côté ici on met mille barrière pour
empêcher cela je pense que ça sera
contre sa propre volonté isabelle ans je
pense qu'on peut dire les autochtones
peut-être certains d'entre eux peut-être
nombreux aussi ont manifesté une
frustration il ya parce qu'on n'a pas
entendu des mots comme abus sexuels
parce qu'on n'a pas entendu des excuses
au nom de l'institution mais est ce
qu'on peut conclure tout même que la
majorité d'entre eux
reconnaissent cet effort extraordinaire
jeu pape de venir quand même ici
s'excuser
je peux parler au nom de tous mais
effectivement le fait que le peuple se
soit déplacé en sol canadien pour se
rendre dans des communautés autochtones
entre autun et kalou est ailleurs il
s'est déplacé du côté de masse kw à 6
oui effectivement on peut reconnaître
cela bien sûr comme je disais l'accueil
de ses excuses la de cette demande de
pardon là pour certains c'était post
suffisant pour d'autres c'est un bon
début et on espère des actions
subséquentes évidemment donc c'est
beaucoup ce que j'entends dans dans mon
entourage pour plusieurs on pensait
aussi que c'était peut-être il manquait
de vocabulaire ce sens que justement on
n'a pas nommé les délits sexuels les
agressions sexuelles on aurait aimé
entendre certains mots je pense que ça
aide à la guérison pour d'autres aussi
on aurait aimé que le pape s'adresse
directement et demande pardon
directement aux survivants et non pas à
dieu un peu comme il l'a fait dont il y
avait quelque chose d'un peu externe qui
a peut-être moins rejoint certaines
personnes mais bien sûr on reconnaît
l'effort qui a été fait par le pape de
se rendre au canada c'était une demande
en fait depuis 2009 il ya eu plein de
délégations autochtone se sont rendus ou
va être quand même le titre hugo en 2017
a fait une demande aussi au pape en ce
sens là donc ça datait pas d'hier et ça
bien sûr pour plusieurs survivants
c'était important
on attend des gestes concrets l'epad
devait encore prononcer quelques
discours après tout est à québec demain
après-demain et kalou et de vendredi
dans ses gestes concrets et isabelle
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'il pourrait dire on a souvent parlé
des archives le jeu relative aux
pensionnats on a parlé d'artefacts qui
se trouve au vatican qu'est ce qui
pourrait faire d'ici ont des parts à cet
égard
il ya plusieurs choses qui peut faire
moi je pense que c'est important
évidemment qu'il donne un accès entier
qui enlève toutes les barrières l'appui
qui donne le feu vert à l'accès au
niveau des archives les ars et les
archives privées autant que les archives
générales donc les archives aussi
individuelle pour qu'on puisse comme je
le disais déjà à dans les émissions
précédentes
rassembler les différentes pièces du
puzzle du casse tête qui va faire en
sorte que c'est à travers cette vérité
là qui va être révélé que plusieurs
survivants et enfin de survivants
puisque les conséquences on le dit elle
sont multi générationnel vont trouver un
certain réconfort et une certaine
guérison donc ça c'est une première
chose les artefacts bien sûr je pense
que c'est ça c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction mais aussi quelque chose pour
le train peut nommer c'est l'abolition
de cette fameuse doctrine de la
découverte oui oui qui ferait très
important et ça c'est une demande qu'on
entend beaucoup de la part de leaders
autochtones au canada buffy sainte-marie
la chanteuse très connue par exemple je
l' ai vu qui a fait une sortie il ya
plusieurs leaders politiques aussi qui
demande que l'église revoit sa doctrine
de la découverte puisque c'est ce qui a
fait en sorte au xvème siècle que les
pays colonisateurs ont pu justifier
moralement la prise des territoires que
cette neige c'est pourquoi s'était rendu
lui je crois ce que c'est le ciel ont eu
lieu cette erreur ça sonne exactement
sous terre 100 m et donc ça a été
vraiment importants comme l'église
jugeait que les habitants des nouvelles
des nouveaux pays où des nouveaux
territoires qui étaient découverts et le
laissant entre parenthèses n'était pas
habitée par des gens civilisés et qu'il
ne connaissait pas aux dieux qui n'était
pas chrétien mais alors ça à justifier
moralement la prise des territoires et
donc la prise aussi des habitants du
territoire donc et c'est ce qui a fait
en sorte qu'on ne plus instaurer des
lois comme la loi sur les indiens qu'on
a pu faire la mise en réserve dans ichat
et rome ça a été très lourd de
conséquences et c'est une doctrine qui
est pas encore aujourd'hui à ce jour en
2020 une mise à l'index donc c'est ce
qu'on demande au cir voyez un peu votre
philosophie en lien avec justement les
autochtones un peu partout à travers le
monde parce que dans la commission
vérité réconciliation on demandait à
l'église justement de sa d'abroger c'est
tout c'est une bulle papale ou un décret
papal donc ce qui n'a pas été fait le
gouvernement fédéral dans sa danse en
adoptant la déclaration des nations
unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones
ah ah
affaiblis ou renoncé à cette clause du
terrain nu cela mais cela dit est ce que
l'église elle mesure outils ou alain
crevier est ce que l'église a fait un
pas dans cette direction là c'était une
ouverture quelque part allen ce que
c'est les initiés oui je pense que ce
serait assez facile de
radier cette affaire là parce qu' elle
n'est plus en vigueur c'est à dire c'est
quelque chose qui est mort et qui est
dans les archives mais qui ne plus force
de loi dans les 10 alors à ce moment là
ce serait relativement simple de le
faire et je suis bien d'accord avec ce
que on vient de dire madame picard et là
son engagement d'hier et de la dgi une
pas une partie importante de ce
processus consiste à mener une sérieuse
recherche de la vérité et pour ça
s'apprend l'ouverture des archives
l'ouverture des archives personnelles
comme on a souligné des archives des
congrégations c'est en train de se faire
pour ce qui est des archives vaticanes
elle-même vous savez que à bibliothèque
et archives canada
on trouve sur microfiches toutes les
archives du xviie siècle
parce que c'était subventionné par le
gouvernement du canada un projet du
centre du conseil national de la
recherche scientifique en sciences
humaines on a alors c'est pierre
hurtubise roberto pérenne
cocody niveau là également qui ont
rassemblé et
c'est monumental ce qu'ils ont fait et
c'est trop ignorée mais les archives du
vatican
qui concerne l'amérique du nord
francophone sont déjà on peut les
consulter à bibliothèque et archives
nationales du canada ah non ça c'est
important à la une remarque là dessus au
sujet de terrains nus sous des achats
sur la question des archives jeu
souvenez-vous il ya quelques peut-être
un an deux ans quelque chose comme ça ce
même pape avait dit dans le cas du
dossier des prêtres pédophiles aux
diocèses de aider la justice civile et
d'ouvrir les archives il a dit ça et je
me suis que chez certains avocats il y
avait comme un petit sourire dans l'air
mais en même temps les archives c'est
quelque chose de particulier quand
françois a été élu j'ai voulu donc
essayer d'obtenir des correspondances
procès de vérifier certaines allégations
qui tournait autour de sa personne
autour des années soixante dix est ce
que j'ai voulu savoir en appelant le g
le bureau de général des jésuites à rome
c'était sa voix est ce que vous
conservez cette imbrication la conserver
la correspondance entre vos provinciaux
et le bureau de la maison de la
compagnie de jésus ce que vous conservez
ses archives c'était comme si je les
avait insultés profondément oui les
conserves bas j'ai jamais eu la réponse
comme tarzan doutez bien je m'en doutais
bien mais j'essaie juste vous dire à
quel point c'est sensible les flamands
ont maudit de rome on me dit monsieur
cette conversation va prendre fin
immédiatement
un kart wii parce qu'on ne voulait pas
répondre à savoir est-ce que vous
conservez ou pas dans vos archives
certaines conversations alors quand on
dit maintenant ouvrons les archives j'ai
comme l'impression que des communautés
qui vont être plus frileuses face à
reparler de ça parce qu'il ya des
dimensions protection de la vie privée
même enseigne un poisson de la
conférence des évêques là on va reparler
de ça parce que s'interrompt pour voir
donc la pâte mobiles entrée dans le
stade du commonwealth denton et on voit
on voit la foule à on a vu une
papamobile effectivement protégés par
des plaques si glace je présume mais qui
sont ouverts 1 il est tout va sur le
côté tout de même et le pape donc doit
faire le tour du stade on va écouter
parce que la réaction de la foule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vous propose de joindre
maintenant quelqu'un qui a voyagé avec
le parc depuis rome c'est un des
journalistes étaient du voyage il est
correspondant au vatican pour le
quotidien la croix on retrouve donc
loupé mon de senneville bonjour
bonjour alors on voit on voit le pape
souriant heureux d'être là il fait beau
ça dit il était fatigué tout de même cet
homme de 85 ans qui est en décalage
horaire est ce qu'on vous a dit comment
il se portait
oui bah évidemment après les deux
derniers jours et particulièrement la
journée d'hier qui a été voilà vibrante
ceci pour le pack france warcq et
évidemment sans doute une fatigue qui
commence à te dégoûte avec pas faire à
450 il a des douleurs au genou droit
qu'il est chaud de se lever en coup là
d'ailleurs le tour de paca mobile qui
des transferts il est un sou dans la
parano dizaine ont de nouveau comme il a
pu l'être pour d'autres voyages donc oui
évidemment la fatigue commence on
commence à peser mais effectivement
comme vous le dites de l'air heureux
d'être là on voit qu'il prend le temps
de saluer la foule réunie dans ce stade
badminton où nous trouver dites moi à ce
que vous avez pu parler à son at-on ans
à son entourage comment on évalue
l'accueil fait à ces demandes de pardon
tiers
alors c'est quelque chose tout commence
à être le lieu noir je n'ai pas
tellement on a bien entendu dans
l'entourage certaines critiques voilà
selon lesquelles j'ai bien le pape
aurait pu aller plus loin notamment en
glanant l'action de l'église elle même
et non pas de faire simple membre et je
tente pas tu as été bien entendu par
l'entourage mais en même temps on dit
que françois ne peut pas aller vraiment
plus loin en tout cas sur cet aspect
global ce qui reste à voir
maintenant et pour la suite du voyage se
voit être qu'à d'autres actes ils vont
être posées notamment iard chine
notamment les artefacts des musées du
vatican pour sa part est ouvert et c'est
des choses qui pourront éventuellement
se passer dans la suite du voyage pour
les quelques jours qui restent cependant
sans dont je vous parle on doit le pacte
groupe ce soir se lever pour saluer une
personne dans la foule bah oui on va
écouter lundi mais voilà elle est en
train de prendre un bébé dans ses bras
et le salut et qui est un grand
classique du tour de papamobile
dans dans les stades durant les voyages
catteau
alors évidemment oui cc c'est un moment
important pour lui de prendre contact
comme ça que ses fidèles dont on sait
que certains d'entre eux sont venus
d'autres pays là on a vu des gens de
l'argentine entre autres ah bah voilà là
c'est la petite fille
voilà effectivement on voit le pacte
soit trop gâché dans la foule maintenant
il s'est levé donc voyez comme quoi les
problèmes de genoux sont bons à la fois
très nettement étendue tentiez important
qui conditionne des pour être présents
parmi la foule est
dense pour la
10 e
tacle très conscients des manquements
dans son discours d'hier à savoir
reconnaître les torts de l'institution
le fait aussi qu'il n'est pas mentionnée
parmi les ennemis qui l'a mentionné il
n'a pas mentionné les abus sexuels est
ce que ça c'est sale c'est préoccupant
ce qu'ils l'ont noté ça
alors je fais pas qu'il y en aurait plus
je n'ai pas parlé avec eux en tout cas
il a mentionné quand même tout type
d'abus une aventure née sous les abus et
moi il me semble que dans ce qu'il
advient et comprenait aussi les abus
sexuels
pendant les années physique et
psychologique est le bouc c'était assez
large et il n'y a pas beaucoup une autre
option tu as eu d'abus sexuels et voulu
qu'il soit rendre compte la butte soins
que la meinau sexuelles dont les a vus
chimiques et au su des bulles et d'abus
de pouvoir de manière beaucoup plus
large
donc vous pensez que on a bien noté
aussi que les autochtones et comme une
autochtone attendre quelque chose au
niveau des archives religieuse relative
aux pensionnats et qu'en est-il au
niveau des artefacts qui se trouve au
vatican à ce qu'on a pris bonne note de
ça
alors c'est un sujet qui avait déjà été
abordé enfin ma début avril alors que la
délégation
d'autochtones était venu à rome au
vatican pour rencontrer le cas de
françois donc le chèque à des
discussions qui sont en cours
avec cette demande a bien été entendu la
partante et qui pensent que l'on fait
passer la manière dont ils auraient pu
honorer et à la manière dont on veut pas
répondre à mes collègues étaient dans
les jours qui vont venir ah oui un bon
alors maintenant ce qui concerne la
messe qui s'apprête à célébrer je pense
que comme deux scénarios possibles
ou bien
la célébrera entièrement lui même ou
sera seconde et n'est ce pas
oui voilà exactement
la même il célèbre la première partie
qui est la célébration de la parole dont
elle
le legs du pain de la vie notamment je
suis après pour la partie musicale si il
y avait frappé par quelqu'un d'autre je
le suis pas mais qui sait mais quand
même depuis quelques jours il est quand
même à 6 à peu près tout le temps donc
il est probable que ce soit plus qu'elle
devienne chez mario se déroule mais je
vous dise la frontière
oui il est un peu après visible ce pape
on le voit on est heureux là parmi cette
foule mais il se tient debout dans sa
papamobile
en soit il n'est jamais plus heureux que
leur fille née dans la foule et
lorsqu'il est au contact des gens c'est
pour cela qu'ils continuent à faire des
voyages c'est pour ça qu'ils continuent
à aller saluer les gens et qui veut
faire de rome du vatican voilà pour
vivre son rôle est vraiment ici sur le
terrain en tout cas les liens entre
antalya un tout petit bébé qui doit
avoir en droit
donc voilà donc sans la clé vraiment
suspension et les verts au milieu
exit mais cette scène ville en sait
aussi que les organisateurs de cette
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui ont prévu donner
la communion faire communier quelque 65
mille soixante mille personnes est-ce
que c'est habituel sen lors de voyages
de pas où
oui alors enfin il ya quand même une
certaine habitude des réalisateurs au
voyage pas pour deux paires communiqué
plusieurs milliers de personnes
c'est bien organisé il va y avoir
plusieurs îles plus pas plus tard 1205
points mais on avec ce dépôt ce qui le
carré et qui va être possible et la
soude donc j'avoue c'est quelque chose
d'assez d'acea mutuel vient alors de ce
loup bassement béant de sa vie je
remercie infiniment d'avoir collaboré à
notre mission merci
merci à vous et bonne suite bonbonnes
suite à tous aux auditeurs merci
beaucoup au revoir
alors allons reprendre minima une foule
nous aussi par l'intermédiaire de will
dean est qui se trouvait lui aussi à
l'intérieur du stade à l'intérieur du
stade a d'abord dit non
on mesure pas vous dire que vous êtes là
oui oui je suis l'un m'attendais oui
très bien alors on ne mesure pas on n'a
pas une vue d'ensemble du stable pour le
moment mais est ce qu'il est mais vous
paraît plaît
alors je gérais il ya beaucoup de
personnes mais il n'est pas encore plein
ce stade je vous laisse voir de plus vos
propres yeux donc vous voyez à plusieurs
milliers de personnes mais ce qu'on nous
avait dit tu es 65 mille places alors
voyez certains sièges qui sont vides
actuellement que ce soit sur le parterre
mais aussi les différents sièges qui
sont au stade là alors on verra est ce
que ce sont des gens qui sont tout
simplement en retard ou bien qu'ils ont
choisi de ne pas venir parce que nous ce
qu'on nous avait mentionné c'est que
tous les billets les 65 mille billets
avaient été distribués dont on verra
plus tard aujourd'hui comment ça se
déroule alors je vous dirais vous l'avez
entendu vous même c'est un accueil
vraiment bel accueil encore une fois
vous entendez la foule en ce moment ce
bel accueil qui a été réservé au pape
françois on l'a vu il ya eu des enfants
qui lui ont été amenés les embrasser ses
enfants alors les gens ont continué à
applaudir ce qui marque aussi c'est ce
bruit des tambours dès l'entrée du pape
françois on a entendu cette hambourg là
est vraiment c'est une messe qui
s'apprête à commencer une messe dans
laquelle les autochtones les peuples
autochtones seront au coeur les thèmes
de réconciliation de guérison et
d'espoir également des membres des
communautés autochtones participe à la
célébration de cette mais cela que ce
soit à travers des lectures ou des
champs on veut que certains éléments
forts de la culture autochtone soient
mises de l'avant soit mis de l'avant
entre autres la place des grands mères
des aînés ce ne sont que quelques
exemples qui seront mis de l'avant
aujourd'hui voilà durant cette messe
autre chose à surveiller vous en avait
déjà parlé la geneviève avec vous
invitez c'est à dire la communion à plus
de 70000 personnes peut-être moins avec
ce qu'on voit ici au stade commonwealth
qui sera effectué entre
à 12 minutes on nous a dit ça sera tout
un défi est aussi le vêtement que
portera le pape je suis pas réussi à
avoir là encore certaines là c'est le
parc déjà ce vêtement ou si ça sera
quelque chose qui va mettre un peu plus
tard aujourd'hui
alors voilà comment ça va se dérouler
ici au stade et plus tard le pape qui
sera use également au lac sainte anne
pour cette célébration de cette messe
cet après-midi merci beaucoup il dit
n'être pas plus tard au revoir alors oui
on s'interrogeait ainsi les vêtements
que porte le pape sont ceux qu'il
portera pour célébrer la messe je pense
qu'on peut dire alain qu'il s'agit du
vêtement traditionnel du pape ce qu'on
veut lui se passe à oui c'est que oui
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a découvert le 13
mars mai 2013 c'est un peu tout le monde
par surprise vous m'ayez porte pas les
apparats bissiau non mais mais il n'est
pas se poser des comme ça et les lames
mais c'est parti comme une traînée de
poudre il fera pas les choses comme les
autres ah non ça prenait justement quoi
ce qu'ils portent là je vois bon avec
une robe blanche une espèce de chasubles
par dessus la blanquette acte photos que
vous voulez de besoin c'est d'une autre
époque et vous allez voir c'est
réciproque si une certaine proximité
c'est pas des injures en rien demandé
non il ya toujours eu
quelque chose de très particulier chez
lui dans sa façon de se déplacer dans sa
façon de s'habiller parson de sade de
s'adresser au monde ça en dirait chance
en dérange quelques-uns qui sont plus
proches des traditions mais bon c'est
sûr mais là vous avez vu des images d'un
homme qui est très à l'aise cette
évidence est guère ceux qui sont allés
pendant qu'ils étaient là
on voit bien que c'est pas pour lui une
douleur que de se promener dans la foule
de serrer des mains de parler à des gens
de sourires beaucoup plus à dire alors
là c'est le temps que le pape se dirige
vers le lieu d'où sera célébrée la messe
il ya la maîtresse de cérémonie
qu'explique un petit peu le déroulement
tout ça qui va présenter certains
discours qui va aussi un moment donné
par vidéo expliquer aux gens comment ils
vont pouvoir communier à la fin de cette
messe en attendant je vous propose à les
joindre à l'extérieur du stade charles
le bourgeois qui est tout d'abord de ce
fameux stade du commonwealth charles
midinettes me disais tout à l'heure que
le stade n'était pas encore plein c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui arrivent encore
c'est ça
oui alors pour tout vous dire j'ai moi
même été assez surpris en arrivant sur
les lieux parce qu'on attend plus ou
moins 65 mille personnes pour cette
messe vous pouvez le voir juste derrière
moi il n'ya pas il n'y a pas foule n'y a
pas énormément de personnes d'ailleurs
on a pu accéder sans trop de problèmes
aux abords du stade jusque dans les
escaliers de là où je trouve je peux
avoir une vision d'une partie du stade
il ya encore énormément de fauteuils
vides et je vous dis aux abords sasso ça
se calme la foule n'a pas l'air de de
continuer d'arriver donc peut-être que
l'essentiel est déjà arrivé j'ai pu
m'entretenir avec plusieurs personnes
qui vont participer à cette cérémonie
notamment une autochtone qui participait
hier à masquer watches aux excuses
solennelles formulées par le pape elle a
été très touché et ça lui a donné envie
aujourd'hui de participer à cette messe
elle s'est dit qu'elle pouvait pas ne
pas venir alors alors que le pape et est
sur ses terres ici à edmonton c'est une
chose qu'elle vivra une seule fois dans
sa vie je vous propose de l'écouter
m
vous venez d'entendre une survivante
d'un pensionnats pour autochtones de
sade lake dans le nord au nord-est de
edmonton elle explique donc c'est la
seule occasion pour elle de participer à
une messe ici à edmonton avec le pape
françois j'ai interrogé d'autres
personnes quelques curieux sont là ici
non autochtones mais qui veulent
participer à cet événement historique et
notamment une femme par exemple qui a
pris congé aujourd'hui elle prétend être
malade près de son employeur pour
pouvoir participer à cet événement au
service de la réconciliation dit elle
d'ailleurs pendant cette baisse c'est un
prêtre originaire du diocèse de calgary
qui prépare l'événement il est d'origine
métisse et crds il est aussi d'origine
italienne donc sa langue en italien lui
permet d'organiser l'événement avec le
vatican cette célébration catholique
aura également des airs de traditions
autochtones parce qu il explique qu'il
ya comme un pont qui peut se faire entre
la culture et les traditions catholiques
et autochtones c'est le père cristiano
bouvette qui suit le pape pendant tout
son périple jusqu'à ical witt vendredi
prochain
merci beaucoup au revoir charles
bourgeois edmonton
alors voilà le moi je constate que en
tout cas le stade
n'a pas fait le plein
je crois que le parterre nuit balle lui
aussi n'est pas tout à fait plein on
voit toutes ces places réservées en
particulier ou survivants hier on se
pose la question m'assois site on
attendait plus de monde ou si on n'a pas
eu autant qu'on attend qu'on pouvait
espérer que le pape que l'entourage du
pape pouvait l'espérer allez on peut
dire aussi que le choix du parcours des
lieux visités par le pape
s'était pas des choix qui était qu'ils
allaient nécessairement encourager la
participation des catholiques canadienne
et on nous a dit à peu près dès le
départ que ça l'est peut être pas été
alors je pense que ceux qui voulaient
faire l'album base au talent ailleurs et
je pense que c'est parce que c'est
comment voulez vous ne pas faire le
parallèle avec jean paul ii jean paul ii
1984 ont déjà aux caisses qui vient
faire chez nous mais ça a déferlé à
partir de québec jusqu'à montréal et
puis ensuite jusque dans l'ouest
canadien ça attire beaucoup mais ces
termes le 50 ans mais que ça fait déjà
40 ans
le monde a changé depuis et l'occasion
n'est pas la même ici on a un homme de
85 ans qui vient en principe parler de
pardon d'excusés de tragédies jean paul
ii venait célébrer autre chose c'était
un homme tenait tête à l'est pas il
était surprenant survivant d'une
tentative d'assassinât peuvent c'était
quelque chose c'est difficile c'est
cruel de comparer les deux mais
spontanément leur faire mal je me dis si
le stade n'est pas plein si hier ce
n'était pas pleinement que l'eau tout ça
c'est passé si je me disais je pense pas
que ce soit comme ça qu'on puisse
évaluer le succès de cette entreprise là
je pense que le super six le nombre
d'agents qui s'y rendent non je pense
qu'on retiendra pas dans l'histoire
comme il y avait des gens hier il commet
un en-avant de sièges vides aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on retiendra la démarche de
cet homme qui a voulu pousser plus loin
essayer de trouver une solution entre
julie avec toutes les imperfections
qu'on connaît on sait que ce n'est pas
il n'y a pas d'unanimité ça laisse
encore des cicatrices et des séquelles
mais je pense que c'est ça qu'on
tiendrait non pas le nombre de sièges
vides dans le stade de moncton mais cela
dit ça dénote quand même les problèmes
de l'église catholique en on peut penser
que si y a pas fait le plein au stade
même s'il a attiré des gens de rentrer
au pays c'est que l'église ne se porte
pas très bien et que la réputation
qu'elle a à l'égard de certains crimes
d'hier est certain qu'elle a commis à
l'égard des pensionnats où les crimes
sexuels les crimes de prêtres pédophiles
ont nui à son image si ça m'apparaît
comme aide et miam indéniable écoutez
porter le porter attention au tour de
vous quand il est question de l'église
ça ne prend pas cinq minutes avant que
seydou sylla face au freinage et on
s'est levé on sait bien on disait
l'église à payer tellement cher pour son
inaptitude à tenter de résoudre ces
questions là
sonorisé de france de résoudre cette
histoire toujours de la même manière
c'est à dire que c'est pas moins
institution qui est responsable de
toutes ces choses même si cher que ça se
passait alors on s'est toujours aussi
douce en mai et le pire c'est que dans
le cas des crimes sexuels on voit la
quantité depuis que les lois ont changé
au québec on voit la quantité de recours
collectif qui va en croissant et nos
pandémie on ne s'est pas aussi facile
pour les lisent et c'est vraiment un
défi un obstacle considérable
ajoutez à ça le fait je pense que le
monde le monde le monde chinois changer
les gens sont peut-être plus éloignés
qu'avant de des questions religieuses je
sais pas y ait quelque chose qui a
changé profondément
on verra on verra ce qui va se passer à
québec demain et après demain mais il
révèle le choix de badminton comme
premier
point de chute pour le pour le pape
c'est pas anodin c'est parce que c'est
en alberta je crois qu'il ya eu le plus
grand nombre de pensionnats pour
autochtones oui une pardon oui
effectivement c'est aussi vous le savez
monsieur l'élan chalon le parler hier
qui était un des commissaires de la
commission vérité-réconciliation donc
c'est son sens sa communauté à lui donc
c'est de là qu'il est originaire et ça
je pense qu'il ya eu quand même là aussi
certains jeux d'influencé à ce niveau là
mais bien sûr l'alberta a été
extrêmement touché par les pensionnats
et par tout ce qui s'en est suivie on
parle des abus mais on parle aussi de la
fameuse tuberculose la fière qu'on avait
des chiffres incroyables il ya eu des
pensionnaires ou la moitié les étudiants
ont été atteints de tuberculose
c'est quand même assez effarant donc oui
effectivement ça a été un des choix qui
a été fait pour ça ouais en ce sens là
c'était précisément le pensionnat
l'ancien pensionnat dans mesrine la boue
dans les années 20
c'était la moitié des élèves de
la tuberculose monsieur outils donc ce
pape françois enlevé très heureux dans
la foule ça fait partie c'est un de ces
bonheurs simples ou pas parce que c'est
pas donné à tout le monde de faire des
bains de foule comme ça avec des
milliers de personnes mais ça fait
partie de ces bonheurs à lui oui et ce
qu'ils recherchent et on l'a vu même le
premier à son arrivée à la réunion pas
la rencontre est important pour lui et
ça a été encore beaucoup plus chaleureux
non pas avec les officiels quoi qu'on en
dise le premier ministre où la
gouverneure générale mais lorsqu'il
s'est mis à rencontrer les personnes
autochtones c'est là que comme si les
choses s'étaient dégeler c'est devenu
plus informelle plus spontané et plus
chaleureux également et dans la foule
c'est ce qu'il retrouve également scellé
venue ici c'est pour favoriser la
rencontre et ça il le fait ici mais il
l'a fait également avec d'autres il est
allé aux émirats arables unis avec des
leaders du monde musulman ce qu'il
cherchait la rencontre parce que il a
cette conviction ferme que nous sommes
tous frères et soeurs et ses 200 ce sont
dans ces cliques fratelli douter c'est à
dire nous sommes tous frères et soeurs
et c'est ça qu'il veut créer finalement
et je suis d'accord avec
alain crevier c'est à dire ce n'est il
faut pas évalué en termes de normes
c'est qu'est ce qui restera de cet
événement est ce que ça a contribué
quelque chose pour vous dire un moine
qui vous vous connaissez ces moines
algériens dont on a fait le film les
hommes et des dieux est un moment donné
on lui a dit mais qu'est ce que vous
faites en algérie il n'y aura jamais de
conversion vous pouvez pas faire de
prosélytisme et il a répondu ce qu'on
nous demande ce n'est pas de faire
nombre mais de faire signe et si on
arrive à un signe vraiment signifiant
d'un rapprochement de reconstruction de
ponts de rencontre on aura fait signe et
on évaluera pas simplement en fonction
du nombre j'aurais pu être significatif
et avoir une portée au delà de si on
avait rassemblé 65 me sens bien sûr
d'autant plus qu'il ait vu ainsi très
médiatisé cette visite du pape en corse
il faut encore faut-il que le signe
soient vus et on peut dire que l'église
catholique là la pratique en tout cas de
la foi catholique a diminué
considérablement depuis le dernier
voyage d'un pape ici où il s'est
pleinement canada et tout ce qu'on a dit
et juste d'une part
pour les raisons qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure l'église a perdu non seulement
de sa superbe mais également de sa
crédibilité ça c'est certain d'autre
part il faut mettre ça dans un contexte
plus général ce sont les institutions
qui ont perdu de leur crédibilité que ce
soit l'institution judiciaire policière
le parlement les institutions n'ont pas
la coop qu'ils avaient il ya trente ans
on se réunit sur la base réseau et non
pas sur des appartenances à des
institutions et là on a changé le monde
mais effectivement également la
dimension religieuse n'occupe plus la
place centrale dans la société et dans
la vie des individus kg plus occupée
jadis
est ce que vous croyez qu'une visite
comme celle là même si le pape n'a pas
choisi de faire le plein de monde qu'il
aurait peur s'il avait par exemple
choisi montréal où zidane benton mais
est ce que vous croyez que cette visite
papale va réveiller un peu la pratique
catholique
j'allais dire c'est pas un magicien qui
est victime vient c'est un pape et c'est
toute la différence 1 c'est à dire ce
qu'on procède avec une pensée magique on
pense que dans une semaine on va comme
on retourne une crêpe changer la
situation
ce n'est pas le cas on l'a déjà certains
l'ont déjà pensé après 84 ça n'a pas
tenu le coup de fouet à dire et c'est la
même chose de congrès eucharistique
qu'on a vécu à québec on a cru que ça
allait à remplir les églises le
lendemain mais ça c'est la pensée
magique
c'est cet autre manque ça procède
effectivement ça va toucher beaucoup de
monde par exemple les personnes qui sont
là et les personnes également qui
suivent l'événement à la télévision
parce que il faut se rendre compte
également que c'est un peu compliqué
s'il faut se lever à 3 heures du matin
pour être dans le stade
ou pour être à sainte anne de beaupré je
sais pas la semaine prochaine le 28 pts
non cette semaine il ya les vêpres à la
cathédrale de québec eh ben pour il faut
être là à trois heures pour des vêpres à
17h15 adore
il faut se lever de bonne heure c'est
vraiment un cas oui
absolument
non c'est le parcours du combattant
parfois pour se rendre à ces grands
événements également et je comprends en
raison de la logistique de la sécurité
et c'était avait alors parlé moi un
petit peu de ce qu'on voit sur scène en
ce moment les éléments essentiels la
célébration d'une telle mais ce jeu
c'est pas à l'aise si vous avez aussi
des informations là-dessus est ce qu'on
peut supposer que certains de ces objets
qu'on a entraperçu son hôtel ont été par
exemple emporté du vatican ou six aces
quel échelon ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle
n'est pas ça c'est vraiment le domaine
de gilles est excellent la dame à tout
ce que je pense tout ce que j'avais
commis dès ce matin en venant ici je me
disais voilà une occasion en or pour
l'église catholique de de montrer
qu'elle n'est pas exclusivement romaine
je lui ai dit ça y est rangé je te
parlais même je pense un mot sur la
bolivie il ya des célébrations des gens
qui sont autres un chrétien très
catholique mais qui fait pas dans le
décor des traits de la liturgie romaine
ni européenne et il ya rien à faire ils
voient les bonnes idées vont faire ça
c'est dans leurs traditions non là une
occasion extraordinaire on est un moment
extraordinaire dans son spectaculaire et
je crois que pour l'église il ya une
occasion en or de montrer qu'elle n'est
pas exclusivement européenne et qu'elle
est capable de faire preuve d'un
plusieurs c'est un mot tellement à la
mode inclusion dans l'âme dans la
liturgie dans le respect des coutumes et
des traditions et la spiritualité des
autres thèmes au coeur de tout j'espère
je pourrais nous aimait la chasse pas
qu'il y aura de sol alors j'ai qu'est ce
qu'on s'est justement le seront d'ici
qu'est ce qu'on sait de cette de cette
messe qui sera célébrée on sait qu'on on
veut faire une place aux traditions
autochtones
mais les éléments essentiels d'une messe
y sont ou si j'entre aperçoit quoi la
statue de la vierge sans doute la vierge
marie
puisqu'on célèbre la sainte-anne
aujourd'hui alors à ce que c'est là vers
où sa mère
oui je n'ai pas une information
privilégiée là dessus mais
certainement vêtements parce que celle
qui l'a le designer qui l'a imaginé
j'oubliais à cauzac a donné une
conférence de presse le 22 juillet
dernier à edmonton et elle a dit j'ai
est celle là je cite un extrait de sa
conférence de presse j'ai essayé
d'exprimer dans la traditionnelle et
indigènes et combinez cela avec
l'art de ma foi catholique alors il y a
au moins dans le vêtement que portera le
papé et le décrit un peu
est ce que dans les vases sacrés ou dans
l'art est ce que dans le mobilier
comment on va concevoir le lieu de la
parole de la proclamation de la parole
l'hôtel parce que ça c'est imaginable
qu'on puisse intégrer dollar ou quelque
chose parce qu'on voit ça même dans
plusieurs réserves dans des églises
plusieurs réserves si vous allez à
natashquan si vous allez la romaine etc
vous allez trouver ça alors qu'est-ce
qu'on sera aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
mais j'ai hâte de découvrir avec vous
parce que comme disait
alain le concile vatican 2 disait déjà
qu'on peut avoir des adaptations et dans
la musique peut-être qu'on va trouver
quelque chose je sais pas une chorale de
betsiamites qui se prépare à
faire à chanter à sainte anne de beaupré
je suis à peu près sûr qu'il y aura des
chants de tradition ou en langue
autochtone et ils convoient combiner la
tradition catholique est également l'art
autochtone mais je l'espère et j'espère
qu'on pourra qu on sera allé le plus
loin possible et même non seulement dans
le mobilier mais également dans la coupe
la patène je sais qu'à québec ce sera
pas le cas mais cela remontera on se
servira de choses non pas qu'ils
viennent du vatican mais qui viennent du
xviie siècle
au coeur de tout ça et c'est une
question vivante dans l'église à ses pas
c'est pour moi le jeu inventé rien mais
la question de la liturgie de l'église
catholique elle se veut universel elle
se veut il ya des éléments qui doivent
être respectées partout sur la planète
dans le monde mais comment faire comment
faire pour conserver cette chose c'est
qu'on la reconnaisse tout jouer toujours
c'est assez universel c'est ok tout le
monde fait en gros ceci mais en même
temps à respectueux et respecté les
traditions des uns et des autres est
plus que ça arrivait à respecter aussi
la spiritualité dans ce qu'elle a de
plus profond dans nos façons le régional
et je pense que si un pacte capable de
comprendre ça c'est lui parce qu'au
début de son pontificat il mois savez le
diocèse de tels endroits sur la planète
est bien mieux placé que moi pour savoir
ce qui est bien ce qui est mal dans
cette région dont il y avait déjà une
ouverture sur les périphéries sur la loi
des choses lointaine et le respect ces
choses là mais c'est un réel débat est
ce que je vais vous dire s'extrait une
réelle question comment fait on pour une
liturgie qui est universel je suis pas
lille surgissent avec le respect de tout
ce qu'il ya autour dans l'est est une
question qui se pose est de façon aigüe
pour ce voyage ici
relatives au relatif aux eaux pensionnat
autochtone et c'est monsieur cristino
bouvette qui était chargé justement de
coordonner la liturgie et cet homme
christine ou bouvette est à la fois un
homme d'église 1 et c'est aussi mais
c'est ce hit amiens par sa mère métier
c'est je pense que j'étais inutile
isabelle ou quelqu'un ce que l'un
d'entre vous
il parle en italien
est ce que l'un d'entre vous connaît
monsieur christine you move est peu
venteux nous en parler il a eu un rôle
très important dans l'organisation de ce
voyage je suis bien sûr on en a entendu
parler évidemment de par sa connaissance
de la langue italienne bien sûr et de
par ses origines métissées et christ
votre emploi ou crient au genou et je
pense pas que ce soit une 8e monde donc
c'est de cette façon là dont on entendre
on en a entendu parler mais ce n'est pas
quelqu'un que qu'on connaissait le à
travers le canada avance alors là on
voit en ce moment merci isabelle on voit
en ce moment phil fontaine qui longtemps
ont été le chef national de l'assemblée
des premières nations c'est lui qui a
négocié pour les autochtones cette
fameuse convention relative aux
pensionnats une convention règle est
signée en 2006 et qui prévoyait un
dédommagement
peut-être pourriez-vous nous raconter la
suite isabelle dédommagement pour pour
les survivants et leurs proches
oui en fait c'est toute une histoire on
parle beaucoup de la responsabilité de
l'église dans tout ce qui s'est passé en
lien avec avec les pensionnaires et il
ya une convention de règlement qui était
signée en 2006 où l'église de vin versé
25 millions de dollars aux survivants
l'église seulement et c'est dans les
meilleurs et fort oui je sais pas ce que
c'est c'est important c'est ce qui va
faire en sorte que plusieurs années plus
tard malheureusement ils n'auront réussi
qu'à ramasser 4 millions de dollars et
il ya un juge de la saskatchewan qui va
leur dire vous avez tout fait ça dans
les meilleurs efforts dont on vous
relève de cette obligation là et ça ça
n'a pas très bien passé évident 1
l'église s'est défendu en disant 'vous
savez peut-être qu'on n'a pas réussi à
avancer tout l'effort mais on vous a
donné des services en nature comme débat
timbres des trucs religieux
alors alors voilà ce qui a amené est
maintenant en septembre dernier
l'église canadienne je sais plus trop
comment elle pourrait préciser mais les
évêques ont dit mais on va aller de
nouveau de l'avant avec un 30 millions
qu'on va amasser mais encore là il était
d'amasser ces fonds là avec avec les
croyants les pèlerins et n'aurait pas au
sein de l'église alors oui et là ça
c'est un problème ça pose le problème de
responsabilité de l'église puisqu'on est
comme le fardeau incombe aux paroisses
et en fait voilà ils n'ont pas l église
elle-même et c'est une raison non c'est
un poisson dit au sujet de ce 25
millions jamais amassé en totalité que
c'était avant la découverte détente de
kamloops et qui avait pas cette émotion
encore chez les paroissiens chez les
fidèles de l'église pour donner de
l'argent en fait l'équivalent de ce
qu'ils ont dit je pensais être en
dessous là chacun pour une question
aussi mais qui se posent de multiples
façons vous savez dans certains cas je
pense à terre-neuve où le diocèse s'est
retrouvé responsable de catastrophe dans
des cas de maltraitance j'ai des jeunes
enfants dans les années où exactement et
le foot péi mais là tout va y passer
tout le mobilier y passer alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait on fait des quêtes
spéciales il et les citoyens les
catholiques un peu partout dans le pays
vont redonner de l'argent pour éviter de
perdre ce qu'ils ont déjà payé de la
c6 à un dilemme sérieux alors messieurs
routier je vous invite à nous décrire ce
que nous sommes en train de voir alors
c'est la procession ventre et donc la
liturgie
se met en branle et dans la procession
d'entrée ce qu'on voit actuellement ce
sont les évêques celui qui a une cour
les deux qui ont le coran c'est des
églises orientales l'esepac probablement
de winnipeg edmonton
alors après avant les évêques nous avons
vu les prêtres concélébrants et la
procession se terminera par l'entrée du
pape jusqu'à présent
le vêtement liturgique que porté par les
évêques est assez classique additionnel
classique oui je ne les ai pas vu de
très très près mais il n'y a rien qui
est étonnant et puis j'ai hâte de voir
la chazotte du pape oui et parmi ces
gens donc ils ce sont des cardinaux des
évêques des gens qui sont pour la
plupart d'entre eux à part potager vue
de deux cardinaux canadien
ou des évêques plutôt monseigneur
poissons entre autres sont des gens qui
sont venus de rome là on parle du cercle
restreint d'entourage pape oui alors je
crois que ce sera surtout les évêques de
tous les diocèses de l'ouest du canada
et quelques-uns de l'est il y aura les
quatre cardinaux canadien
à mon point de vue ne sont pas encore
rentrés mais là on aperçoit le pape et
la chasuble à l'orgue aperçu devant lui
le cardinal ouellet pss oui c'est ça
carnaval est elle a effectivement et je
vois son bâton pastoral qui est une
croix mais qui n'est pas la croix
classique qu'ils veulent qu'il est à
rome
donc j'ai hâte de la voir de plus près
mais probablement qu'elle a été fait
pour la circonstance et qu'elle combine
elle aussi de l'art
qui de l'art
amérindien
et
on commence la célébration et on voit
que pour éviter son déplacement et le
présidera au trône mais que quelqu'un
l'assistera
donc j'ai l'impression de loin que c'est
l'archevêque de moncton
et on découvre enseigne à ce métier
voilà on découvre l'hôtel qu'on a un
juste aperçu mais j'ai hâte d'en voir
également la décoration il a
probablement été conçu on n'a pas pris
un hôtel qu'on a déplacé là mais conçu
pour la circonstance
[Musique]
oh
une même où des foires au nom du père
font du fils et du saint-esprit
peas will you que la paix soit avec vous
cent six frères et soeurs les tasses
maintenant laisse très bas mais a
célébré le mystère de leur [ __ ] à
ussel en reconnaissant que nous avons à
pêcher
c
je confesse à dieu tout puissant je
reconnais devant vos frères et soeurs
que j'ai pêché en pensez en paroles par
action et par omission
oui j'ai vraiment péché c'est pourquoi
je supplie la bienheureuse vierge marie
les anges et tous les saints et vous
aussi frères et soeurs de prier pour moi
le seigneur notre dieu
meilleurs matériaux que dieu tout
puissant nous fasse miséricorde à ce
qu'il nous pardonne nos péchés et nous
conduisent à la vie éternelle
[Musique]
les ans
[Applaudissements]
et
les eaux
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
l'état fait
trion
hall autre seigneur dieu
a choisi saint joachim et sainte-anne
14ème pour déposer sa grâce et pour
mettre au monde la mère de ton fils font
le plein hors de nous en ce jour de
cette année à travers la brière de ces
deux cas que nous accorde le salut
promis
par jésus christ notre seigneur vue qui
vit et règne avec dans l'élite du
saint-esprit pour les siècles des
siècles amen
first willy premières lesquelles
gillings femmes de bouaké lecture du
livre de ben sierra lesage
glorieux ancêtres
ont des hommes des miséricordes de
justice n'ont pas été oubliés avec leur
postérité il se maintiendra le bel
héritage que sont leurs descendants
leur postérité à persévérer dans les
lois de la lui en leur temps en temps
ils sont restés fidèles grâce à eux
leur descendance subsistera toujours
jamais leur gloire ne sera effacé
leurs corps ont été ensevelies dans la
baie rivoire et doubt et leurs nom
adresse vivants bactéries
pour toutes les générations
les peuples raconteront leur sagesse
l'assemblée proclamera leurs louanges
parole du seigneur
nous rendons grâce à dieu
[Musique]
d'entretenir
alors messieurs outil on vient
d'entendre une première lecture de
textes par une autochtone de la
communauté enoch
qu'est-ce qui l'a significative pourquoi
at il été choisi ce texte
c'est la lecture de la fête de sainte
injustement sur les ancêtres mais elle a
une signification toute particulière
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de cette
célébration
alors nous nous louons les ancêtres et
quelques-uns d'entre d'entre eux
ont marqué alors ça pour les les peuples
autochtones savoir parler et cette
lecture l'a fait entendre un son
différent aujourd'hui
auparavant nous avons eu parce que c'est
une mais c'est quand même assez
classique et rome a exigé que tout se
passe à l'intérieur d'une heure ce qui
laisse moins de place à la créativité en
raison de
layton n'ont pas de santé mais de
faiblesse et le programme chargé on
tient ce que 7e dans une heure on a eu
au début de la célébration le rite
pénitentielle ce qui est significatif
également dans un pèlerinage fini en
ciel où on a confessé devant dieu et
devant nos frères et soeurs qu'on a
drake l'esad qu'on a pêché gravement
alors ça et c'est également important et
ça vient d'eux lorsque tu viens pour
présenter ton offrande si tu te
rappelles que ton frère a quelque chose
contre toi laisse là ton offrande et va
te réconcilier les confrères
c'est le sens du rite de d'ouverture ray
pénitencier les paroles prononcées par
le pape avant la lecture de ce texte par
la femme autochtone que vous étiez
c'était ça le la prière link en scène
non c'est juste avant
oui parce que il a introduit par frères
et soeurs reconnaissons notre péché et
préparons-nous à célébrer les mystères
sacré en or et c'est là que toute
l'assemblée à
confessé son péché et demander à dieu
départ donné vers leur pardonner alors
on voit maintenant
alors le l'entourage du pape s'est levé
lui même est resté assis je pense qu'on
peut comprendre pourquoi
voilà probablement que la messe va se
poursuivre pour l'instant alors que se
passe-t-il là
alors on se prépare à la lecture de
l'évangile il aura la procession du
livre de l'évangile pendant qu'on chante
les louanges et
l'évangile sera lui même très brefs et
tout de suite après ce sera l'homélie
c'est à dire la prise de parole par le
pape au cours de cette célébration et
cette prise de parole est ce que c'est
un texte sacré qu'il va lire ou se sont
rapidement ce sont ses propres mots
c'est un commentaire de l'écriture il va
revenir sur les lectures qu'on a entendu
mais c'est lui qui va les commenter avec
ses propres paroles et c'est là qui va
livrer un message personnel alors on va
écouter le déroulement de la messe merci
monsieur entier
dans leur voiture
l'oligarque à la programmation
tu sais pas
si
les
mini pro
[Musique]
auj et la fiesta des rossoblu
c'est la fête des grand parents de jc
le seigneur a voulu que nous soyons
nombreux à nous rentrer spécialement
dans cette occasion qui vous est si cher
et qui m'est si chère dans la maison de
joachim et dan le petit jésus a connu
c'est en scène damien iehl a fait
l'expérience de la proximité de la
tendresse de la sagesse de ses
grands-parents bien
pensé aussi à nous et grands parents
solos et réfléchissons à deux questions
essentielles
qui
dort au gaz oil gas d'euros se profile
en 10 hockey
nhl
thaçi keystone les autoroutes
une expérience de pro tools and roll and
wisdom
et louis fois en tout et si
le primero la proposition d'une histoire
nous sommes les enfants d'une histoire
que nous avons préservé lors nous ne
sommes pas des individus isolés nous ne
sommes pas des hommes de l'autre car
personne n'est déconnecté des hôtels à
moins que nos racines l'amour c'est
vivant ne nous attendait et que nous
avons reçues en venions le contexte
familial dans lequel nous avons grandi
cela fait partie d'une histoire
qui nous a précédés plus que nous aussi
généré si nous n'avons pas choisi comme
on veut nous avons reçu ils sont comme
un don d'amour à mal un don pour dire
que nous sommes appelés pour la
protégeons nous en sommes les quartiers
libres avec légèreté go lui remonte la
dette livre de ben htira lesage nous le
dit nous sommes là posté la postérité de
ceux qui nous ont précédé leur bel
héritage
au delà
des pros des prouesses de l'autorité de
certains de l'intelligence ou de la
créativité du champ de la poésie cet
héritage a en son centre la justice dans
la fidélité à dieu et à sa volonté et
c'est cela qui nous ont transmis
pouvoir est pleinement acceptée qui nous
sommes et notre valeur et pour cela il
faut bien que je prendre soin de prendre
soin de ceux dont nous descendons
nos aînés qui n'ont pas seulement penser
à eux mêmes mais qui ont transmis le
trésor de la vie qui
si nous sommes ici c'est grâce à nos
parents
mais aussi grâce à nos grands parents
qui n'ont pas au permis bien m'aimer de
nous sentir bienvenu en ce bas monde
c'est bien souvent ses grands parents
qui nous ont aimé sans réserve et sans
rien attendre de nous
ils nous ont pris par la main quand nous
avions pas
nous ont rassurés au coeur de la nuit
ils nous ont encouragés à l'heure de
vérité où nous faisions face aux grands
choix de notre vie
grâce aux grands parents
nous recevons cette tendresse de
l'histoire du passé c'est bio à plein
d'humour que la band'à nous avons appris
que le bien il à saab la tendresse et la
sai ce film et ce sont des racines
solides pour lui même ou sur des
nosotros
souvent dans la maison des
grands-parents nous avons respirer le
parfum de l'ébauché d'une fois qu'un bon
goût de des familles grâce à eux nous
avons découvert cette fois familial
domicile si oui pour qui la fessée
communiqué essentielle mais c'est ainsi
parce que c'est essentiellement comme ça
que l'on transmet la fois arrivé dans la
langue maternelle ou en dialecte à
travers l'amour l'encouragement le soin
et la proximité
danny
boyle unique je suis d'accord si grâce
ndg evos life
without shoes déchetterie oui steve
harper
from any grand prestige au retour
angie et evry hinson au port tree hill
centre high speed
milliard
us we are we need to accept we need
cette expérience va men and women from
your death and all
his
band
et
l'oise
butch vig social à
3,5 stood m oui de skavsta kind of
failure fait à des merveilles
des cases d'arrêt sera offert et
fondamentaux y par stone india model
town in day one
here espaces théâtraux mme chow au fait
qu elle incrimine
crowsnest
telle est notre histoire il faut en être
les gardiens celui de l'histoire dont
nous sommes les héritiers pour que se
maintenir nous sommes des enfants parce
que
dès qu'on part en août après dix ans
nous la marque originelle de leur façon
d'être complaisant donné la dignité la
confiance en eux-mêmes et la confiance
en les autres
nous ont transmis quelque chose qui ne
pourra jamais être effacée à l'intérieur
de nous et en même temps ils nous ont
permis d'être des personnes uniques
singulière libre
et c'est justement que la baule aux
grands parents que nous avons appris que
l'amour n'est jamais une imposition
qu'elle ne prive jamais l'autre de sa
liberté intérieure wakim diane c'est
ainsi que jacques laumaillé et anne et
me marie
aimée l'issue et c'est ainsi que marie a
aimé ou jésus avec un amour qui ne
trouve pas qu'il ne retient pas mais qui
accompagne pour qu'il puisse embrasser
la mission pour laquelle il était
vraiment à blâmer dans ce roman une
vidéo su comment essayons d'apprendre
cela non en tant qu'individu la wagon et
en tant que classe ne jamais opprimés la
conscience de l'homme ne jamais enchaîné
la liberté de ceux qui sont proches de
nous gaver hmam et surtout ne jamais
oublier des murs de respecter ceux qui
sont venus avant nous et qui aujourd'hui
sont confiés à nous ce sont des trésors
précieux qui conserve une histoire qui
est plus grand
que
la taille unique marque en
france
nle
elle
fera 39
me
back par la combinaison
arena
tout proche le
dos et nos beaux vos nerfs tout fait et
moi
elle respecte dean dossou président
abbas annoor in trust iii care for des
infrastrutures
sens
préserver l'histoire qui nous a engendré
des musées comme le dit le livre de même
s'y rattachent 'cela signifie
nous ne pas obscurcir la gloire de nos
ancêtres sans perdre la mémoire ne pas
oublier l'histoire qui nous a donné la
vie et toujours nos repas les rappeler
le cema qu'ils ont caressé qu'ils ont
pris dans leurs bras que donnerait
notamment parce que c'est là la source
retrouveront la consolation dans les
moments de découragement alors me
trouveront la lumière à l'heure du
discernement et le courage pour
affronter les défis délicats mais être
gardien de l'histoire qui nous a
engendré cela veut dire aussi revenir
toujours le monde à cette école nous
avons deux véhicules et scellée pipasso
décision d'aujourd'hui cela veut dire
aussi nous demander qu'est ce que ferait
les personnes âgées plus haché le thon
en conserve ainsi il était à notre place
et que nous conseillerais où nous
conseillent nos grands parents nos
arrière-grands-parents
de 9 heures
oui selon will remember d'eau douce and
craft and food and drug
source
ils me sortent ce que je m'en aille tout
cas hélas un corps de fille y
est
soumise comme tony do
it means of sinners où elle fit wear
daily show is one of the top 10 à 12 h
nos
frères humains
demandent en outre manche il signait
nous sommes nous que savez mon couteau
deux enfants avec qui l'enfant qui
aiment qu'ils savent être les gardiens
de la riche en annonces lavoix nas
enseignants c'est ce que nous souvenons
bien blâme ou ce beau aux enseignements
irritée notamment une pelle ou au
collège avec les personnes âgées est-ce
que nous prenons la sauce te laisse
écouter harris mars et qui par nos jours
plus cléments moderne avec ses pour moi
avec l'étalon n'est pas ce que nous
avons commencé un soir sourit quoi lever
pour y conserver ses souvenirs qu'on
peut gagner sans toit de notre spécial
un petit somme qu'avait rivages de
lâcher au fil des images et des objets
nos pensées et nos prières vers ce
témoin construisons précédé est-ce que
nous avons conservé la bible ou le
chapelet de nos aînés l'union qu'on ait
fait prier pour eux et en réunion avec
et consacrer du temps à faire mémoire
préserver l'héritage
dans le brouillard de l'oubli qui
envahissent notre époque vertigineuse
coup mes frères mes soeurs
il est important de prendre soin glace
il faut prendre soin des races et c'est
ainsi que l'arbre grandi et c'est ainsi
que l'avenir se bâtit
children
under
the
wide web
marlène france
doit
disputer
ce match
4 gbagbo de rougerie bits
et les essais
et les i thank you
for
eric et time to remember
grosse
déception est
fondamentale en
plus d'être fils d'une histoire à
préserver nous sommes partisans d'une
histoire à construire
chacun d'entre nous peut se reconnaître
pour ce qu'il est lourd avec ses
lumières et ses ombres
selon amour qu'il a reçus ou qui lui a
manqué c'est le mystère de la vie
humaine pour commencer nous sommes tous
enfants de quelqu'un oui mais nous avons
tous été engendrée et façonnés par
quelques uns mais en devenant adulte la
main nous sommes aussi appelé à donner
la vie être des pères des mères et des
grands-parents de quelqu'un
en regardant la personne que nous sommes
devenus aujourd'hui
on doit se demander que voulu faire de
nous mêmes ce vraiment les grands pères
de nos souvenirs et les personnes âgées
qui ont rêvé espérer et se sont
sacrifiés pour une question fondamentale
quel type auld et sociales quel type de
société voulons nous bâtir et mon récit
lui total nous avons tous reçu des mains
de ceux qui nous ont précédés
laissé en héritage à notre postérité
une foi vivante ou une fois à l'eau de
rose une société fondée sur le profil
des individus ou sur la fraternité ou
même un monde en paix moi un monde en
guerre
une création dévasté où ils seront
encore accueillante
britannique deep run the
world
is also
to anyone with
my boss hans scharoun et mbaye fall of
pale rider 2 au dynamo cif
veste mystery of human life
we want someone ce changement bic a in
chut bas jan ader par as we become
annonce oui tour contre guy waïss du
biophare hamad
via
twenty one big windows ou camara
saoudatou
au rwanda continue
stabilité et
n'oublions pas que ce mouvement qui
donnera des racines aux branches il a
failli l'ophlm fleurs aux fruits de la
lavande et la tradition la véritable
tradition s'exprime dans cette dimension
verticale ropal de base en
prenant garde à ne pas tomber dans la
caricature de la tradition ne voulut pas
en ligne verticale une des racines ou
fruits mais bien en ligne horizontale de
la de l'avant vers l'arrière
qui nous conduit à la sous culture de la
marche arrière comme on a refusé go easy
qui ne fait rien d'autre qu en fermer le
présent dans une boîte et le conserver
dans la logique du on a toujours fait
we need to be careful
il faut
un bac
à
16 882 souhait
dans
l'évangile jésus dit aux disciples
qu'ils sont bien heureux parce qu'il
peut voir et entendre il faut ce que
beaucoup de prophètes de justes ont
seulement qu'il fait désirer
beaucoup en effet avait cru à la
promesse de dieu concernant la venue du
messie il avait alors réparez son chemin
et avait annoncé son arrivée à laquelle
mais maintenant que le messie est arrivé
au calame ceux qui peuvent le voir et
l'écouter à damas sont appelés à
l'accueillir et à l'annoncé
ait pu
manipuler
elle proclame
énorme
fresque murale et par cela vaut aussi
pour nous m ceux qui nous ont précédés
nous ont transmis une passion ou la fois
une force et un désir au fouet un feu
qu'il nous appartient
de raviver
il ne s'agit pas de garder des cendres
mais plutôt de raviver le feu qui l'ont
allumé
grands parents et nos aînés ont désiré
voir un monde plus juste plus
fraternelle plus solidaire ils ont lutté
pour nous donner un avenir
à nous maintenant de ne pas les décevoir
gamme à savoir soutenu par eux qui sont
nos racines c'est à nous de fructifier
la base de la et parce que la tradition
c'est la fois donné favori de la combine
à la religion' ali ne la transforme pas
en
traditionalisme et la fois comme a dit
un penseur
soutenu par eux sont nos racines
nous devons comme je les dis les faire
fructifier nous sommes les branches qui
doivent fleurir et introduire de
nouvelles graines dans l'histoire alors
faisons nous quelques questions
concrètes face à l'histoire du salut à
laquelle j'appartiens et face à ce qui
mettrait aider et aimer moi qu'est-ce
que je fais l union sujet un rôle unique
et irremplaçable dans l'histoire mais
alors quelle trace vais-je laisser
derrière moi
que vais-je laisser à ceux qui me
suivent
que vais-je donner de moi très souvent
une mesure de la vie en fonction de
l'argent que l'on gagne de la carrière
que l'on réalise plus du succès de la
considération que l'euro ne doit
désormais ce ne sont pas des critères
ferron il faut plutôt se demander est-ce
que je donne canada est-ce que je donne
la vie est-ce que j'introduis dans
l'histoire un amour qui auparavant n'y
était pas annonce que j'annonce
l'évangile là où je vis amen est ce que
je suis au service de quelqu'un il
rationnement comme ceux qui m'ont
précédé
qu'est ce que je fais pour mon église
pour ma ville pour ma société
la critique est facile
mais le seigneur ne veut pas que nous
soyons sur le monde des personnes qui
critiquent le système il nous voyons il
ne veut pas que nous soyons fermé et que
nous fassions marche arrière mais que
nous soyons des artisans d'une histoire
nouvelle comme on l'a dit
il veut que nous soyons des tisseurs
d'espérance quand des bâtisseurs
d'avenir déficit des artisans de paix
nrj est
mort trop
tôt
et les audois states
holdings fait par des
prises de
profits à sanaa
ce stand by the world now the
french damas
entre news
est
unique
kevin walls of
income très peu
de jeunesse et magazine life
& mining life
et marne et
newmont mining
[Musique]
avance tôt son président me dit fourmis
waiting for the
series
exit faire
un tube i wrote in gbagbo
à 16
diatribe
berdos au fioul pis mais
aucune y animer et anne intercède pour
nous préserver l'histoire qui nous a
engendré metal des années leur bâtir une
histoire féculents nous rappelle
l'importance des rituels d'honorer nos
grands parents et nos aînés
de mettre à profit leur présence en pour
construire un avenir meilleur on vous
donne aucun avenir alors joue les
personnes âgées ne sont pas rejetés
parce qu'elles ne sont plus
fonctionnelles
photo un avenir qui ne s'use pas la
valeur des personnes
seulement par an pour leurs produits il
fallait un avenir que ne soit pas
indifférent à ce qui est fait c'est
désormais plus âgées ont besoin de plus
de temps déconvenue et d'attention 1
avenue où l'histoire de violence et de
marginalisation sur bip a subis par nos
frères et soeurs autochtone ne se répète
personne c'est un avenir possible si
avec l'aide de dieu nous ne romprons pas
le lien avec ceux qui nous ont précédés
et si nous alimentons le dialogue avec
ceux qui viendront après nous jeunes et
aînés grands parents et petits enfants
allons de l'avant ensemble né manquent
rêvons ensemble vraiment et n'oublions
pas c'est faux le conseil a blow à sunny
side deux pôles associant d'ici-bas
timothy rappelle toi de ta mère et de sa
grand mère
mais ce chiffre
est faux
inaugurée et perfume et futurs des
espaces et
saint josse ten
noode
alors voilà c'était le ferment du pape
au coeur de cette messe célébrée au
stade du commonwealth à edmonton en
alberta
monsieur routier un commentaire sur
cette mini évidemment fait sur le thème
on en a parlé plus tôt dans l'émission
de la grand parade parentalité un de la
transcription par les aînés oui et un
petit bout ils s'expriment en espagnol
moi je pense qu' à un clin d'oeil à y
aller langue d'autochtones qu'il faut
préserver et moi je parle aussi dans ma
langue maternelle
est plutôt que de dire on va prendre un
espèce de nouveaux latin qui est
l'anglais
évidemment il n'est pas à l'aise en
anglais mais plus que ça il ya un
message à travers ça alors il ya des
petits mots prendre soin de ses racines
quand il dit la langue maternelle à la
fois et les reçus dans la langue
maternelle dans le dialecte là il visait
précisément quand il parle d'héritage et
il est revenu plus d'une fois sur nos
racines
mais c'est en même temps l'histoire qui
nous précède
l'histoire que l'on construit et
il dit maintenant quelle que soit
notre situation avec
notre héritage fait d'ombré de lumière
nous avons à construire une société est
donc là il ouvre vers l'avenir pas
simplement sur la grande part en grande
part en qualité mais il va essayer la
fin on dit en latin une cauda venenum
c'est à dire c'est dans le lac -qui le
venin c'est à dire dans la
il va dire maintenant
nous lui présentons toutes nos pétitions
pour la sainte église de te tuer
puisse-t-elle demeurer fidèle à la
mission qui lui a été confiée
d'aller de l'avant et de faire les
disciples de toutes les nations et de
proclamer l'évangile
du seigneur
prions le seigneur
seigneur entend notre prière
pour les diligences des nations
puissent-ils travailler au service du
bien commun et pour le véritable progrès
de tous les hommes et de toutes les
femmes prions le seigneur seigneur
entend notre prière
gelée
pour les personnes âgées pour les grands
parents
puisse-t-il être choix lié est respecté
et partager avec les enfants leur
présence avec les jeunes l'europe
et avec les adultes la chose la sagesse
de lausanne et prions le seigneur
seigneur entend notre prière
pour ces chemins de l'art et à ceux des
puits sont nourris au tour de la table
que l'or le carillon et reconnaître que
nous sommes tous enfants d'un même père
et frère et soeur les uns des autres
prions le seigneur seigneur entend notre
prière
reçoit nos prières dieu tout puissant en
exil
nous te le demandons au nom de ton psg
hulot qui est notre seigneur pour les
siècles des siècles seigneur entend
notre prière
[Musique]
les
le sait
et
non
[Musique]
à
oh
et
c'est ans
alors voilà pendant qu'on prépare la
cérémonie de noeux caristie ce sont des
gens d'origine autochtone qui présente
justement au pape les vases qui vont
être utilisés à l'hôtel de l'est
caristie voudrais monsieur route si vous
terminez votre pensée tout à l'heure à
propulser rement du pape vous parlez de
la la queue et du venait vous voyez quel
état d'âme chez de son ami ni le punch
parce que ici nous situe dans la
tradition nous venons d'une histoire et
nous avons désormais à écrire une
histoire à bâtir et là ils posent des
questions qu'est ce qu'on va faire
quelle société voulons-nous bâtir et à
la toute fin il dit un avenir où
l'histoire de violence et de
marginalisation subis par nos frères et
soeurs autochtone ne se répète pour
personne c'est un avenir possible etc
alors oui d'où on vient
mais que voulons-nous faire maintenant
quel avenir voulons nous construire
ça c'était sa finale oui isabelle ce
qu'il y a quelque chose dans le sermon
du pape qui suscite une réaction
j'ai beaucoup entendu oui ce futur ce
renouveau là évidemment ce sont des
idées qui
comment entendu qu'ils étaient quand
même très fort il ya aussi l'idée des
racines de prendre soin des racines pour
que la grande piste on a tendance à
liart aussi dans son discours concernant
les excuses et sa demande de pardon
et c'est quelque chose qu'il avait
utilisé aussi si je ne m'abuse au
vatican et je trouve que l'analogie et
les beaucoup mieux réussi
que lorsque hier il avait comparé la
croix et le lard ou médecine par exemple
ouais moi ce qui m'a frappé aussi c'est
le rôle des grands parents dans la
transmission de la tradition de la fois
il a même utilisé le mot dialecte nous
son métier si je ne me trompe pas et moi
je trouve cela remarquable parce que
j'ai pensé à tous ces petits enfants
autochtones qui n'ont pas bénéficié de
cette transmission du savoir et de leur
langue puisqu'on les a arrachés de leurs
parents et de leurs grands parents
[Musique]
à
oh
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
et
moi
[Musique]
m
ça
c'est
[Musique]
e
on
lucie
dominus vobiscum
retour sur le support à benton
grazia games domino day lost in you may
use du msv reding matthew stone est et
courts métrages ou tard et nos stylistes
un père robrig ratissage les domaines et
saint patern hypothèse est terne et des
us
une somme tout en continuant ses
librairies et les aura le mérite à toi
donna coronas
hynovis et oran conversationnel argyris
exemple on est comme une yoni consortium
et internationaux substitut
attentiste et steve goose confirmatif à
propositon certamen ramos une victime
est une marche similaire commise
couronne de lauriers conséquemment père
christ dont ministre et d'idées ou
mindjet arcangeli une grille multiplient
congrégation et son hymne homeland
typique animaux signifie n'est dit chez
nous
[Musique]
verison pousser ce combiné est méritée
la dette pour nice était candidat
créatures pierre philion tourner dominé
l'australienne kristie spirit santé
opérante vérité
vérification scientifique à son univers
alors si je fais appel à vos
connaissances parce que bon c'est
l'enseignant limites
l'archevêque badminton qui prononce
cette quoi c'est une liturgie de
l'eucharistie c'est ça voilà c'est la
grande prière eucharistique
et puis ça veut dire que le pape va
présider au trône mais ne se rendra pas
l'hôtel pour présider on ne comprend
compte tenu de ses difficultés à
dépasser son mal au genou voilà pourquoi
il a délégué à la chaîne et que ça c'est
même est loin d'être terminée maintenant
ce qu'on voit là on entend le
monseigneur sunnite
s'exprimer en latin l'espagne dans la
grande tradition un classique de rome
oui la liturgie a été est jusqu'ici
très classique on peut le déplorer on
aurait pu aller plus loin il faut savoir
que il ya toute négociation entre rome
et les évêques locaux ou la conférence
des évêques pour aboutir à la liturgie
et que finalement le dernier mot est
donné à rome qui dit ça va se faire
comme ça
quoi vous avez vous pensé que les
évêques locaux ont
peut-être eu essayer d'obtenir quelque
chose qui soit quoi
je pense qu'on aurait aimé aller plus
loin dans
décoincer un peu si je puis dire le
rituel
et on aurait pu je regarde tous les
servants de messe on aurait pu faire
affaire là des autochtones
démissionner malheureusement on n'est
pas allé aussi loin que ça
et je ne vois pas de trash passe
isabelle elle en a noté mais moi je ne
vois pas de trace on avait parlé d'un
costume de d'éléments du costume du pape
qui auraient été cousus ou qui aurait
porté des symboles traditionnels
autochtones je n'en ai pas vu il faut
dire qu'on n'a pas eu de gros plans mais
pour le reste du ritz eu avec josé roule
en ce moment sur cette scène je ne vois
rien qui puisse appartenir à la
tradition autochtone en voyez vous il y
en a ici et c'est ce que je disais
malheureusement pour le vêtement ils le
portent effectivement
ce n'est pas simplement c'est une
combinaison d'éléments de spiritualité
autochtone et de foi catholique c'est à
dire la description que j'ai lu au moins
c'était avec des symboles du baptême est
il réellement de lui car ici mais il
aurait fallu le voir de dos pour ça
voilà qu'on me donne l'occasion de faire
est bien faite elle que ça viendra on va
donc laisser la prière se pense victime
innovation avec les 6 et nouer avec
nothing special one who use blue et ce
qui est mal actionnée près car on chez
ricoh
primi piatti
s'imaginait est géré et rich et marie
combes et
épuré aux terribles comme ça
merci à tout va
et crosby notera que
dominé a tout au long du match a sans
doute à la 13ème tour par canal in terra
in fédé et carita firent madininair
comme fait mal à tous aux panneaux sur
francesco et fera très maigre et cadeaux
fiscaux
ecclesia aimé indyk nous femmes hulot
tout comme puisque ballet au dîner et on
y verse aux toreros et on y pose aux
acquisitions ni tuer votre famille à
pontivy a star et par le ouistiti destot
procopio
on est filho strauss ou big wade espère
sauce tibi clément ader misratah scan
huguet fra traîneau strauss de forte
hausse et on equity biplace szentes ex
rock s'est clos
troisième ronde et nous réglons tout une
belle nous admettait ou bi forrester
hamas ou dessous mais la gloria doit
prêter sa tumeur creston dominante
nostrum et recoins monde aubenas compte
à la terrasse
ellipses mais comme ils sont d'inite sow
est évidemment très hypothétique il nous
dit à des souris tout senti
on his own les plots dia
et on est assez court assez cool aux
eaux
[Musique]
et
du sauveur et de selon son commandement
vous vous en dira notre père qui êtes
aux cieux que ton nom soit sanctifié que
ton règne vienne que ta volonté soit
faite sur la terre comme au ciel donne
nous aujourd'hui notre pain de ce jour
pardonne nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés et ne nous laisse pas entrer en
tentation mais des louvre nous que mal
ce livre nous de tout mal seigneur et
donne la paix un truc temps
soutenu
nous serons libérés de tout péché
de toute épreuve
nous qui attendons que se réalise la
bienheureuse espérance l'avènement de
jésus-christ notre seigneur car c'est à
toi qu'appartiennent leur haine et la
puissance et la gloire pour le
seigneur jésus-christ tu as dit à tes
apôtres je vous laisse la tête je vous
donne ma tête ne regarde pas nos péchés
mais la froideur n'égalise pour que ta
volonté sa complice d'ennui toujours ces
deux têtes et conduit vers l'unité
parfaite toi qui vit et règne pour des
siècles que la paix du seigneur soit
avec vous et avec votre esprit
donnons-nous le signe de la paix
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
by vols de la mort card
mixer
seniors je ne suis pas digne de te
recevoir mes dix seulement une parole et
je serai guéri
le
[Musique]
ça
mais
hall
[Musique]
m
au
[Musique]
et
et là
[Musique]
plon
sans ça
[Musique]
le
et cela
[Musique]
c'est mieux
or
etc
on
oh
[Musique]
pour
ça
hélas hélas
[Musique]
faux
bah
m
[Musique]
d
et là c
[Musique]
c
breton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en somme
c
mais bon
je vais pas
[Musique]
e
oh
tu sais
mais la sma
[Musique]
à
ça
[Musique]
c
à
et
c
hélas
[Musique]
il y en a
là
son
le jour
aussant
rires ça
[Musique]
c'est
merci
[Musique]
c
cela
[Musique]
à
juste un petit mot rapidement pour
expliquer que cette cette communion
qu'on est en train de faire à grande
vitesse s'est exécuté par quelques 460
prêtres et diacres
même plus que ça probablement 500 et
plus qui sont donc à travers la foule
pour leur remettre le corps du christ
les hosties mais vous avez quel un
commentaire monsieur rouzier concernant
le champ on écoute en ce moment oui
alors le champ communion était composée
spécialement pour la circonstance par
une auteure une autre is down town
bernadette gastein malheureusement nous
n'en avons pas les paroles
j'aurais aimé pouvoir
voix qu'est ce que ce chant 10 pour la
circonstance je veux dire également que
dans les premiers siècles chrétiens
ce qui était révolutionnaire à l'époque
c'était de mettre ensemble des jouets
ted et payet
des hommes des femmes des esclaves des
hommes libres dans un même repas et donc
c'était un geste révolutionnaire de
notre société qu'on voulait construire
une société où on peut partager le même
vin être assis à la même table et ce
geste lors peut avoir cette
signification encore aujourd'hui et ça
serait en phase avec nos melli quelle
bande voulons nous construire et un
monde fraternel où un monde dans
l'ignorance les uns des autres le mépris
d'un groupe par appel par l'autre groupe
alors on avait la personne qui dansera
soir à côté du pape regarder l'heure
parce que c'est la personne qui est
responsable du cérémonial et de
l'horaire du calendrier du pape
probablement et cette eucharistie comme
je disais cette distribution des hosties
devait se dérouler en principe selon le
programme en une dizaine de minutes
après quoi une fois que ce sera fait le
pape doit bénir tout ce beau monde alors
voilà oui on entre dans les rites de
conclusion est probablement qu'on
n'attendra pas que la distribution de la
communion soit terminé pour y aller avec
les rites de conclusion ray de
conclusion donc qui consiste de la part
du pape à bénir la foule et de la part
de monseigneur smit qui a qui a
finalement célébré la messe la tour
va remercier 7,7 archevêque de newton va
remercier le pape archevêque qui soit
dit en passant a travaillé très très
très fort pour cette visite papale parce
qu'il a accompli c'est lui qui a
coordonné cette visite ici au canada et
il a accompli en quelques mois quatre
mois ci prend habituellement non à
préparer alain
quelqu'un au diocèse de québec me disais
c'est généralement 72 ne sais pas
pourquoi sur 100 m 72 semaines de
préparation nom
du seigneur dieu ton fils unité unique
et de ness de la famille humaine pour
que celle-ci par amir admirable le
mystère renesse de ta propre vie
oui bay d'attentats mieux on s accorde
l'hommage à ce que tu as nous a eu du
pain de tes enfants tu être sanctifié
par ton esprit adoption le whif de blad
uhry
bloqué par le christ notre seigneur
hamel
au
nom de mes frères nous sommes tous ici
réunis pour cette célébration
eucharistique je tiens à vous donner mes
chaleureuses mis à genoux votre voyage
apostolique
rempli de promesses que vous avez fait
de venir ici au canada et cela démontre
à quel point vous êtes proche de nous
tous et tout spécialement à quel point
vous êtes proche des premières nations
des métiers les illimitée de ses terres
nous reconnaissons et nous apprécions
l'effort colossal personnel que cela
représente pour vous d'être parmi nous
sachez le nous sommes tous extrêmement
reconnaissante
[Applaudissements]
certains que je doive continuer très
simple lot mais je en octobre n'a rien
donné a annoncé votre plaisir de voyager
sur ses terres en appellerait nage de
guérison et de réconciliation
notre prière la plus sincère et que
votre présence elle même face et que
l'esprit de saint pierre soit sur notre
pays et apporte la grâce de la guérison
et de la paix du seigneur sur nos
matches
rimini encore beaucoup à faire
si nous voulons véritablement vivre de
façon durable la réconciliation à
laquelle nous aspirons tous
l'amour et l'encouragement que vous
manifestez visiblement avec votre
présence nous trouvons un nouvel élan
pour continuer à cheminer en continuant
à nous appuyer sur le don que dieu le
créateur nous donne toujours les évêques
du canada sont complètement engagé
acheminés aux côtés des premières
nations les métis et des inuits
la beauté de leur culture nous enrichit
ainsi que la sagesse de leurs traditions
la procession de saint joachim et sainte
anne nous renforce votre soutien
également nous conforte et nous
renouvelons donc notre engagement à
marcher sur le chemin de la
réconciliation avec nos amis et frères
autochtones nous vous souhaitons un bon
voyage et nous vous promettons nos
prières notre respect notre gratitude et
notre amour
comique merci
merci saint père
alors if you may seigneur soit avec vous
votre esprit que le nom du seigneur soit
béni maintenant et pour toujours les
mêmes pour notre secours dans le nom du
seigneur
qui a fait le ciel et la terre et aux
matériaux bio que dieu tout puissant
vous bénisse le père le fils rôle fut et
le saint esprit amen
go in peace à lisant père nous rendons
grâce à dieu
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non
alors la célébration est terminée en
tout cas pour ce qui est du du rhône du
pape et il a prononcé sa bénédiction
finale à tous ses fidèles qui étaient
heureux de se retrouver c'est l'occasion
d'une vie pour certains d'entre eux de
se retrouver comme ça en présence du
pape
chef de leur église et
vous avez vu aussi que plusieurs d'entre
eux étaient nombreux à vouloir prendre
le corps du christ cette cérémonie
eucharistique dans très importante qui
semble avoir été menées plutôt rondement
puisque la cérémonie se fait dans les
temps il ya eu un hommage discret mais
qui devait se faire la statue de la
vierge marie qui a été prêté par une
communauté soutine à la vierge marie
celle qu'on appelle notre dame du cap
qui a délié apparemment avec avec le
québec mais ce routier oui absolument et
plus que le sanctuaire notre dame du cap
et offrir des oblats de marie immaculée
au québec j'ai l'impression que
lien se fait par lasser démissionnaire
joe black marie immaculée qui était
demandé
réserve autochtone et est-ce que vous
avez moi j'ai cherché en vain les fameux
éléments traditionnels autochtones qu'on
aura pu retrouvé sur les vêtements du
pape peut-être peut-être des perles
cousue sur sa mitre le chapeau qu'il
portait à la fin
oui et probablement mais on n'a pas vu
landau de c'est à dire le dos de sa
chasuble mais effectivement on est resté
un peu sur notre appétit on aurait pu
aller beaucoup plus loin dans cette
célébration dans l'inculturation de la
liturgie
finalement toutes les prières qu'on a
récité la grande prière eucharistique
est donné généralement dans des
chapelles où les amérindiens célèbre
c'est tout ça et traduit en langue
autochtone est et il ya des prêtres qui
connaissent ces langues là il aurait pu
être concélébrants et intervenir et
c'est la même chose les servants d'autel
qui vraisemblablement étaient des
séminaristes du diocèse edmonton
auraient pu être des amérindiens oui on
a entendu tout de suite après le sermon
on a entendu quelques femmes autochtones
prénom se lire quelques paroles prononcé
quelques paroles mais c'est pas
davantage minimum c'est oui six mille
balles alors voilà on retient ça on y va
on va les retrouver à l'extérieur de ce
stade du commonwealth où finalement les
autorités nous disent qu'il y avait
quelques quarante mille personnes sur
les 65 me qu'on attendait tiffany alors
à l'extérieur quelles sont les réactions
plutôt positives
isis a été minimale la présence
autochtone mais chaque personne a comme
trouver ce qu'ils voulaient dans la
cérémonie à papale il ya une survivante
autochtones qui m'a parlé il m'a dit
qu'elle savait elle était venue pour son
chemin de guérison dont qu'elle avait
beaucoup d'émotion après cette messe
dépôt émotion assez mélangé à la fois de
la joie mais aussi à tous ces
traumatismes à qui reviennent une autre
une autre autochtones qui m'a dit que
elle l'avait senti beaucoup la parole de
réconciliation dans cette cérémonie est
bien sûr beaucoup de catholiques qui eux
ont vu d'autres choses dans les paroles
du pape certains qui ont entendu le
peuple et les amener à aller plus vers
leur famille à arrêter de penser à leur
carrière alors toute autre préoccupation
et se rapprocher des leurs donc plutôt
des gens heureux à la sortie de la messe
hippie qui ont tous interprété les
paroles du par françois comme il le
voulait écoutez les
[Musique]
et donc vous l'entendez elle vous
l'entendez les gens sont sur le retour
en pensant à qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu
avec le pape certains qui pensent que
c'est une l'occasion d'une vie un
d'avoir vu le pape quelques souvenirs
sont disponibles pour eux s'ils le
veulent elle lie à ce logo du marché
ensemble mais l'organisation papale me
disaient qu'ils voulaient que ces
souvenirs là soit assez sobre homme qui
voulait pas que ce soit une occasion de
financer l'église catholique mais jusque
les souvenirs soient là pour les gens
qui le souhaitaient pour se rappeler ce
jour ci il faut ni
merci au revoir
[Musique]
alors pour conclure tout ça
alain une conclusion générale sur ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui on a vu que le
pape était heureux on a vu que les
fidèles étaient heureux de voir le pape
ils ont communié en grand nombre mais
est ce que on était tous en haine dans
l'expectative en fait d'une plus grande
inclusion de quelque chose de plus de 70
je faisais ça vaccins comme un oui ben
oui il ya la matière peut être réfléchir
déception mais je me dis je peux en
prêter de mauvaises intentions mais
c'est un jeu qui s'appelle cristiano
bouvette à qui on a confié entre autres
l'organisation de la liturgie ces choses
est ce que c'est par manque d'audace que
c'est impressionnant le vatican les
autorités je regardais les cardinaux qui
passait je me dis je parlais l'autre
payet de maintenant je sais pas ce que
c'est l'un c'est ça qui a fait que on a
eu je pense nous de l'extérieur comme
observateur quelque chose qui manquait
qui surtout donnent à ce moment ci de
liste roth mais autrement s'il ya que
les gens sur place pour dire s'ils sont
heureux ou pas du moment qui viennent
vivre nous on n'est que des observateurs
très loin de deux
ans on parlait tout à l'heure d'une
négociation monsieur routier entre les
évêques ici au canada et rome mais rome
semble avoir gagné mais est ce qu'on
peut penser que peut-être les évêques de
québec
auront eu un peu plus de d'influencé ou
de poids et qu'ils amèneront les
cerveaux knicks vont se dérouler à
québec davantage côté autochtone oui je
ne sais pas si c'est rome qui a regagné
ou si comme dit alain on n'a pas été
assez audacieux en leur présentant
quelque chose qui aurait pu être encore
aller plus loin mais quoi qu'il en soit
je pense que la liturgie à sainte anne
de beaupré
j'étais un peu plus près de sa
préparation
sera un peu d'une autre teneur oui oui
vous voulez dire qu'elle intégrera
davantage d'éléments et aux autochtones
en tout cas
je le dis parce que je l'espère mais je
pense que ça sera un peu le cas aussi à
propos de ce qui va se passer décerné à
québec on apprend on apprend dernières
heures que le maire de québec ne pourra
pas participer aux cérémonies puisqu'il
est il a contracté la co vide
parlons de covè justement on a vu des
gens masqués aujourd'hui moi je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser que ce sont des
cérémonies qui peuvent
disséminer la maladie alors on va
évidemment
prier ou se croiser les doigts pour que
ce soit pas le cas isabelle vos
commentaires vous par rapport à ce qui
vient de se passer cet événement on a vu
on a vu des autochtones on a vu
d'ailleurs une femme brandir la photo
sans doute d'un proche peut-être
survivants des pensionnats alors vos
commentaires à l'égard de ce qui vient
de se passer au stade du commonwealth à
edmonton ben pour ma part je m'attendais
à être très occupés a expliqué un
symbole autochtones ou un autre ça n'a
pas été le cas donc moi aussi j'ai quand
même une certaine surprise je
m'attendais à ce qui est plus d'éléments
autochtone et comme
monsieur routier le disais tout à
l'heure vous savez dans les églises qui
se situe dans les communautés ce n'est
pas rare qu'on traduise des prières ou
des champs dans une des langues
autochtones dans une des 90 langue
autochtone qui reste encore au canada
alors je m'attendais à avoir un peu plus
de saisie de ces éléments là on verra
maintenant la suite comment ça va se
passer à sainte anne de beaupré mais ça
pour moi c'était c'était un petit manque
mais encore là s'il y en avait trop usé
c'est toujours un jeu dangereux je
comprends que c'est un enjeu qui est
plutôt délicat
mais je m'attendais à ce qui est quand
même un petit peu plus lui même la
fameuse chasuble de madame préparé par
l'adam kozak jeu l'ipo vu peut-être y
avait du perlage derrière mais c'était
très très simples ou très timide alors
tous les trois je vous remercie beaucoup
gêné routier isabelle picard alain
crevier on vous retrouve ce soir pour ce
grand pèlerinage que le pape va faire
enfin il va se rendre à ce lieu de
pèlerinage toujours en hommage à sainte
anne est ce c'est un lieu et un haut
lieu de pèlerinage autochtone alors nous
sommes convaincus qu on verra là
davantage de tradition autochtone
intégrer avant de quitter le stade de
moncton je vais retrouver à l'extérieur
charles le bourgeois qui a suivi toute
cette messe vous avez couvert charles
beaucoup de déplacements pontificaux
comment caractériseriez vous celui ci
oui normalement le peuple françois en
voyage apostolique et bien affermir la
foi des fidèles catholiques ici c'est
très singulier car le pape fait un
pèlerinage pénitentielle il est là pour
demander pardon donc la ferveur
l'intensité est un petit peu différente
je me trouve présentement avec une des
porte-parole francophone de la visite du
pape au canada erika jacentes aux
mairies car est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner vos premiers sentiments 65000
personnes devaient assister ce matin au
stade est ce que ça a été le cas on
parce que ça a été aux alentours des 40
milles et on passe les récents c'est
parce que il ya des personnes qui ont
pris environ six billets puis sont
utilisés moi que ça lorsqu'ils se sont
présentés et par contre notre notre but
initial et final c'était d'accueillir
tout le monde puis y est gratuit et je
pense que l'obus a été vraiment qu
ailleurs toutes les personnes qui
étaient capables de venir c'est ma terre
à la messe merci beaucoup ja sentai je
vous rappelle que pour la suite du
programme le peuple françois partira au
lac sainte anne en fin d'après midi
aujourd'hui alors charles le bourgeois
qu'on a déjà vu au vatican couvrir la
délégation autochtone au moment des
premières excuses au moins d'avril et
qui suivit donc cette visite sic et
suivi ou si le trajet de survivants en
route pour
voir le pape entendre le pape formuler
ses demandes de pardon charles bourgeois
merci beaucoup au revoir bientôt voilà
qui conclut cette émission spéciale ce
soir je vous le rappelle le pape se rend
donc au lac sainte anne c'est au
nord-ouest de newton à peu près une
heure de route c'est un haut lieu de
pèlerinage pour les autochtones
catholique qui génère la grand mère de
jésus nous y serons c'est un rendez vous
à compter de 18h30 heure de l'est merci
renfort
[Musique]
ans
ça hachez les
[Musique]
oh
chapeau
[Musique]
oh